[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
all righty bonehead of the week
[Music]
you already know who it is
of course there were as many candidates
this week that could have been the
bonehead of the week
welcome Friday welcome welcome around
the world audience to the Tony Michaels
podcast I am the Tony Michaels
as you know every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch as
long as Twitter is still around and also
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page and my Facebook page as
well
so there's all kinds of places you can
watch it you can also download it on all
your favorite directories but today is
Friday and as you know
Friday is our favorite day because in
the second hour of the show we do
bonehead of the week everyone's excited
about bonehead everyone know who is the
biggest bonehead this week
isn't it obvious
he lost his party and he lost his
[ __ ] mind I don't mean to give it
away but God damn how could this not be
the bonehead of the century
I mean really honestly what
what do you want from me I didn't do
this I didn't do this to us I think it's
kind of funny though
did you did you now if you don't have a
true Social account you didn't go over
to True social obviously but did you see
the screenshots
from the Cheeto dust q and honor Grandpa
[ __ ] his diaper last night oh my God
absolutely [ __ ] losing his mind
right out in the open
like for everyone to see how crazy this
sumbitch is can you believe that that
[ __ ] was President of the United
States
that he was one one coat away from
launching nuclear war holy [ __ ]
this guy is not only just unstable and
unhinged
he is unfit and unqualified to even be
on social media
she
I mean I've had a lot of [ __ ] crazy
trolls in my life and some some people
say some crazy [ __ ] online
crazy [ __ ] but they don't normally
say [ __ ] like they interfered in an
election in 2018 like they don't
normally say that kind of [ __ ]
especially when what they're saying
about in in election interference could
possibly be real now this is the thing
really about this um
I don't know if you know and we'll
probably show them here today
um obviously
hell we always get a trudge through the
nonsense it's hilarious though this is
this is funny [ __ ] I don't I mean you
know a lot of people like this is
dangerous and I real I mean dangerous to
who to to Grandpa I mean really honestly
he's putting himself at risk here
not just not just to absolutely alienate
himself from all the the entire party
but all of his supporters
because he's supposed to announce that
he's going to run and he was going to do
it next Friday and now he's gonna do it
Tuesday or some [ __ ] I don't know
is he going to do it isn't he going to
do it I want the [ __ ] to run
that's what I want it'll absolutely
destroy him and then I absolutely
destroy the Republican party don't stop
please
I mean while this party is on the ground
crying we need to make sure that they're
kicking each other
because that's what this is this isn't
this is not a situation where it damages
democracy for Ron DeSantis and and
Donald Trump
to try to figure out who's the king of
the idiots
I mean that's really what they're
[ __ ] arguing over is who is the king
of the minority of votes in this country
that is literally what they're arguing
over
they're gonna rip each other apart tear
each other apart destroy any kind of
political Capital that they may have
gained from this midterm which is
absolute zero
the only person that really has any
political Capital here is Ron DeSantis
because he gerrymandered Florida good on
you buddy
and he's gonna destroy that by going to
battle with Donald Trump
when he should have just been the boot
licker he's been the whole time if Ron
DeSantis would have came out and
declared Victory and said it was all
Donald Trump's doing and he asked to
thank Donald Trump only for this I mean
this wouldn't be happening
this wouldn't be happening because
that's really if you look at the midterm
that's really the only big win that they
had I mean yeah they won the the seat in
Ohio and and Greg Abbott won in Texas
but their biggest Victory overall was
the state of Florida that was one of
their biggest victories everywhere else
they [ __ ] lost and really it looks
like the the scenario that I laid out
yesterday where it could come down to
house control to One race which is
Lauren bobert
rather she wins or she loses
that's what it could come down to here
I I mean that's what we're gonna find
out I mean it's gonna take a little bit
Jesus Christ I don't know why it takes
some of these days so [ __ ] long to
count
and we talked about that yesterday
they're kind of burning each other to
the ground
because they lost
they didn't win the midterm this this
[ __ ] nonsense were like oh well
Republicans could win the house you're
talking by one vote even if the
Republicans win the house you're talking
by one vote one
you're not even gonna be able to get
impeachment on the floor you dumb
[ __ ] the best thing you're
gonna do is talk about Hunter Biden's
laptop for two years as committee chairs
and you're going to destroy the
institution of our Congress and
everyone's going to see it play out in
plain as day and you're not going to get
[ __ ] done and it's all going to be
blamed on you
what are you talking about that's why we
carry the message now we carry the
[ __ ] water of the message in the
country not these [ __ ] idiots they've
done so well the last several Cycles but
the last two cycles the pro-democracy
people in this country really have
carried the water of the narrative [ __ ]
them
and Donald Trump is losing his [ __ ]
mind because not only was he counting on
this delusional Red Wave it was
delusional just like everything else
[ __ ] delusional that this country was
going to vote for people to take away
their rights
what the [ __ ] are you thinking
that's not they had no platform other
than we want to take your rights away
and then as soon as gen Z votes them the
[ __ ] out and make sure to secure
democracy they're like oh we're gonna
take gen Z's right away from them to
vote
I had a good idea good idea way to
really lean into the whole reason why
you lost and that's what Trump is doing
that's what they do this is their MO
because they have no ideas none
what's a good idea they got name it I
bet fake Gabe couldn't even tell me how
many [ __ ] good ideas they got not a
goddamn single one not a [ __ ] one do
they have a good idea they'd be like Oh
I'm Jim Jordan and real America hates
high gas prices
yes okay
what are you gonna do about it Jim I
don't report sex crimes Jordan
what are you gonna [ __ ] do about it
buddy nothing not a goddamn thing
what church and Walker going to do about
gas prices talk about how the Chinese
air is dirty and we're giving them our
clean air what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
listen
the only political Capital that they
gained on Tuesday was in Florida with
Ron DeSantis and that's what Trump is
trying to do is steal back his political
Capital that he was supposed to gain and
he got nothing nothing
that's what politics is driven on is
political capital and you spend it you
you have to gain it and then you spend
it Biden spent his political capital on
things like the pack act speaking of uh
veterans happy Veterans Day to all you
veterans out there
especially the ones that are super
pissed off that Republicans did their
damnedest to get rid of the PAC deck
Joe Biden spent his his political
capital on the pack Act
he's spending on the infrastructure bill
he spent it on the chips act on and on
and on we could go the the very first
thing that he spent his political
capital on was the coronavirus relief
that no Republicans voted for
that's what Joe Biden spending his
political capital on that's what the
Democrats are spending their political
capital on is stuff that's going to help
America
Rhonda santis and the Republicans are
spending their political capital on oh
there might be people that we don't want
to have wieners have wieners
they're crazy this Matt Walsh Ben
Shapiro did you see the video of Nick
Fuentes saying they want a dictator they
want a dictator because they can't tell
women what to do then they need to have
a dictator to tell women what to do I'm
not [ __ ] [ __ ] you I'm going to
show you the clip
and this is their [ __ ] god this is
the guy that Marjorie Taylor green
wouldn't hung out with went to his
conference went to spoke speak to his
supporters at the America First pack
they're a bunch of [ __ ] Nazis
and they lost because of it
and the head Cheeto dust q and honor
himself
is is scrounging for political Capital
to announce
that's what he's doing
he ain't got a choice he thought he was
gonna have a huge red tsunami that's
what they believed
delusional as [ __ ] I S I was one of the
only [ __ ] ones and you people know it
I was one of the only ones that said we
were gonna [ __ ] there's no [ __ ] way
they're going to vote them in no [ __ ]
way
all the rest of the pundits [ __ ] tyt
David Pacman every MSNBC CNN every one
of these [ __ ] said that the
Republicans were gonna win
every [ __ ] one of them said they were
gonna win what I say what I say
foreign
and it wasn't just my faith in the
American people
it's because the American people don't
put up with [ __ ] people taking their
[ __ ] away from them
especially their [ __ ] rights
you just don't do that type of [ __ ] to
us it's not a thing you do
especially running on it
telling us what [ __ ] books our kids
can read telling us telling us what what
CRT is and what it isn't
telling women they don't have the
privacy of their medical decisions
inside their doctor's office when it
comes to their [ __ ] life
depending on it
yeah I think that's probably a bad
platform
and it paid it paid nothing for them
there was no dividends
for them
none
cause now the political Capital that
they did have they're [ __ ] fighting
over every single little last ounce of
it
and it is it is highly highly probable
that the Democrats because Lauren bobert
loses her seat in Colorado
that Nancy Pelosi is still the Speaker
of the House imagine
how much political Capital they're gonna
have it that's how the votes fall
it's going to be incredible
and it's because of you
it's because of you because you engage
in your democracy you did what you're
supposed to do you did your Civic
[ __ ] duty
and that's how it works that is exactly
how it works
and yeah I get there's some questions
about voting and how long is it taking
and some in this County some of that
County we're going to work that out
folks we're gonna work all that out
we got this
in this election we saved ourselves from
these [ __ ] boxes
and once this is done right we get
finished counting and they certify the
vote they seat these these members of
Congress the Senate the governors that
we won really [ __ ] important the
governorships that we won I don't know
how I don't know how much I can stress
this Shapiro in Pennsylvania Whitmer in
Michigan and if if Katie Hobbs can pull
this out which it looks like she may do
in Arizona those three states
are the [ __ ] are the signatures to
stop
[ __ ] fake ass electors in the next
presidential election
those governors are the ones who sign
those State electors and they have to be
legitimate now because there's a
level-headed people [ __ ] running
those States not some [ __ ] election
denier
insurrectionist nope
these are important things that we did
and we won that's why they're pissed
that's why Donald Trump's [ __ ] trying
to steal away political capital from
DeSantis because that's the only place
that it lies with the Santas
their party's over it's over what are
they gonna do
I hope I hope next week Donald Trump and
Ron DeSantis announce [ __ ] let them both
do it hails to the yeah
hell what's what's get him in a [ __ ]
boxing ring let's do that I don't give a
[ __ ] hell I well change the [ __ ]
primary laws to where they got a [ __ ]
beat each other's brains out I'm good
with that
now I do want to go back to
this thing about the FBI agents
in the Department of Justice for a
minute
the US United States Attorney
in this [ __ ] post on fraud social
the Cheeto dust Q anoner which
I I've changed from calling him the
Cheeto dust mobster to the geodesk Q and
honor have you noticed that that's
because
this illusion that he was a mobster was
always an illusion but now there's no
illusion that he's a q a number so we're
going to change the name the Cheeto desk
cue in honor
goes on a rampage I mean a [ __ ]
rampage
and he's just I I don't know if he was
on the toilet the whole time what the
[ __ ] happened but this guy would not
shut up on Broad Social so much so that
he had he he actually typed out that he
committed a crime now here's the problem
and and I I've said this in in the last
couple weeks too that you can't believe
a single [ __ ] thing that comes out of
this guy's mouth
right I mean he's always projecting and
he's always admitting things you know
basically telling you where the crime
lies
but something makes me think that this
is all [ __ ] that he's just full of
[ __ ] [ __ ] he never sent nobody
nowhere to save Ron DeSantis now if it
is true holy [ __ ] that's that's Insanity
that's Insanity not not that I mean it's
insane that he would do that but it's
insane that he would type that [ __ ] out
and post it for the world to see it's
insanity but that's where we're at
but I I have a hard time believing
anything this [ __ ] says like
anything anything
even if he told me he his hair was a wig
and he's been he's been wearing a wig
this entire time
and he told me nope I put on a [ __ ] ton
of makeup and I'm not this tall I wear
lifts I I would be like whoa wait a
second
I believe this whole time I mean
literally it would it would make my mind
think that he was lying because that's
what he does he [ __ ] he just lies he
just [ __ ] lies and lies and lies now
here's what I actually think it is
here's what I think
we're gonna find out when especially
when these investigative journalists get
a hold of this because when they get
older this they're gonna try to dig deep
of where this was Now read the
Department of Justice actually
investigates themselves or not because
that's what they would be doing think
about it what he's saying is is the
president as the president United States
he directed the FBI in the United States
Attorney
the Department of Justice as it as it is
part of the executive branch he he
[ __ ] directed them to interfere in an
election and to stop counting or
whatever it was that he really claimed
it's kind of unclear exactly what he's
claiming
but if these investigative journalists
get a hold of this here's what I believe
that it is
I think there's little kernels of Truth
and what he what he typed in that
statement where he's admitting that he
committed crime right
and I think the truth of it is he wanted
to commit crime right he wanted he
wanted to commit crime
he didn't he wasn't successful I mean he
[ __ ] fails at everything this guy's a
[ __ ] loser I mean just grade a loser
he everything Trump touches turns to
liquid [ __ ] what do you want from me I I
don't control these things
but I believe the kernel of Truth is
that he wanted to commit crime
he just couldn't get the crime off the
ground there in Florida to do what he
wanted and it just so happened it
happened
to be the way that he wanted it to be
anyways right
so I I'm not really sure and I I know
we'll we'll know this in the days to
come probably sometime over the weekend
we'll get some more reporting
on this guy [ __ ] admitting that he
committed election interference in 2018.
holy [ __ ] but
I will say
I will say that beyond beyond that
um statement where he's admitting that
he possibly committed uh felonies
probably
um in election interference
dude
is isolated
dude is not feeling well
and I don't know if um he ran out of
medication or what the problem is
but he's in big trouble
really big [ __ ] trouble
and he's not very politically
Savvy he's not
I mean everyone's like oh he won 2016.
yeah he won by technicality he lost my
three million votes he got destroyed in
the 2008 midterms he lost by 8 million
votes in 2020. there was supposed to be
this big red wave
this week in this midterm and there
wasn't at all and it's because of him he
sucks at politics folks
he sucks at politics worse than he sucks
at Trump Stakes
and Trump University that is how bad he
is at this
and he can't figure out whether he's
gonna run or not
and he's really trying to get anybody
anybody to tell him that he should run
some Rando on fraud social
some pundit on TV I mean [ __ ] he was
attacking Fox News he's attacking
yanking this morning
the governor of Virginia
attacking yankin
calling him Chinese or some [ __ ] I'm not
kidding you this guy
some people say he's lost his marbles
but I say and I've said it before they
the marbles pack their [ __ ] and they
[ __ ] left they were tired of that
[ __ ] get your get your [ __ ] Danny we're
out of here
I I'm I'm serious he called young and
Chinese or some [ __ ] this morning I
don't know I don't know what it even
[ __ ] means
it might be an inside joke
I don't know there's another story out
there in the Rolling Stones that he's
got
that he's got dirt on DeSantis now
rather that dirt is maybe hey we we
committed election interference I mean I
don't know maybe that's it but even
Rolling Stone won't print that [ __ ] it's
so crazy
he's lost his mind
it's gone
and he's and he's not Tethered to
reality the good news is [ __ ]
lost all over the country
he has no power
no power at all
other than he can announce that he runs
and I don't even know if that's going to
go over that well that might go over
like a wet fart and a white thong
that's why I want him to announce let's
do it [ __ ] do it you [ __ ] [ __ ]
announce I'm here for it and you're here
every single weekday for two full hours
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch do not forget
to subscribe to the YouTube channel
while you're here
you can vote for bonehead of the week
and it's Friday it's Friday bonehead of
the week in the second hour my co-host
and executive producer Gabe Sanchez will
join us
where you vote you to sign who is the
bonehead of the week and we break it
down every single Friday if you want to
vote you can vote on YouTube you can
also vote on Twitter as long as Twitter
is still alive go to at Tony Michaels
POD at Tony Michaels pod
you can vote there as long as Elon
doesn't crash that [ __ ] you can
also download every single episode of
the podcast on Apple Spotify Google you
can download bone net of the week in and
of itself on Sundays too did you know
that just the moon end of the week on
Sundays while you're subscribing on your
favorite directory make sure to leave us
a great review while you're there and if
you're over on the books of face on the
Midas touch Facebook page if you can
hear my voice go at the Tony Michaels at
the Tony Michaels and follow us on
Facebook and you know what a lot of
people like the twitch chat too
go over and follow us on Twitch it's a
simple app you download it it's free and
I don't get paid anything to download
the app or whatever
and I I don't really I don't really know
twitch that well we broadcast over there
there's a lot of people that watch over
there hundreds of people watch over on
Twitch because they like the the chat
it's it's a little different than the
YouTube chat but everyone everyone seems
to like the YouTube chat too and you
guys are here every single every single
day you're engaged you're leaning into
your democracy I'm excited to see it I'm
happy to see it I'm so proud of every
single person in this country that got
out and voted it's super important that
we do what democracies do best have our
voices heard that's the most important
thing that's the most important thing
and when we come back we're gonna go
through the [ __ ] list Roundup I have a
few I have a few videos I want to show
you
um the one being Nick Fuentes but I also
want to talk to Gabe Sanchez about a
little conversation we had with a bunch
of right Wingers on Twitter spaces last
night I don't know if any of you guys
caught this but we were we we ended up
in a Twitter space with a bunch of right
Wingers oh boy was it a delight and I
hope I get to go back they probably
won't have me back though
probably not they probably won't add me
back I don't know probably not probably
not but you will have me back and the
reason why is because you are our
support and we run on your support if
you would like to support us
with a little tip because we don't do
the super chat here on YouTube anymore
but if you'd like to do a little tip go
to Tony Michaels dot live Tony Michaels
dot live you can leave a one-time tip in
the tip jar there or you can set it up
monthly we appreciate all your support a
lot of people are talking about this
shirt though since Ron DeSantis won you
can go to
store.thetonymichaels.com
store.thetonymichaels.com you can pick
up your Rhonda Santos can go [ __ ]
himself merch Ron DeSantis can
definitely definitely definitely go [ __ ]
himself so go pick up
this great merch today that also is
support but more than anything stay
tuned stay here watching stay engaged
share this link with your family your
friends especially Uncle Earl because I
know his Maga tears your Uncle Earl his
Maga tears at Thanksgiving nah it's
gonna go so well with the turkey
everyone stick around we'll be right
back right after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[Music]
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show
[Music]
great
it's Friday what are you guys doing for
the weekend
[Music]
he's gonna go celebrate all the Maga
tears you see out there you're gonna go
bottle them up and drink them
that's what I think I'm gonna do
oh boy I'm gonna get drunk on my guitars
all weekend wasted wasted oh it's so
beautiful isn't it you know the the the
best part about the whole thing is that
they're like oh we didn't actually lose
the Republicans are gonna take the house
well you're not sure that yet we'll see
how this Lauren bobert race turns out
there you [ __ ] nincompoop but they
really they really are struggling
because they're like well
JD Vance you won one you you won one and
you kept the seat you didn't flip a seat
and then the same thing in Florida like
yeah well Florida like yeah well they
gerrymander the [ __ ] out of that
sumbitch and and you didn't flip
anything down there and you didn't make
blue to Red like it wasn't a red wave
where you mean blue it was already
[ __ ] a hellscape
you a Greg Abbott bet Aurora lost
okay
again you didn't flip anything nothing
that you flipped
you really didn't get it going
I mean they've they've flipped I think
uh 14 seats I believe is what they
flipped in the house right 14 14
Democrats have flipped nine
that's not a red wave if Democrats are
flipping almost as many seats as you're
flipping that means you didn't win you
[ __ ] lost
and that's and the reason why they're so
pissed off is because they did lose
and what they really truly lost what we
took from them
and I don't mean to
brush my own shoulders but we took the
[ __ ] narrative away from these son of
a [ __ ]
we took the [ __ ] narrative away from
him for instance last night in this
Twitter space oh it was fantastic what
happened was is Gabe Sanchez you know
him and Christian Walker herschel's son
have this uh
this virtual roommate thing going on
um Gabe Sanchez is blocked by Christian
Walker right he's BL a Christian has
blocked him from all social media
because Gabe Sanchez has made some
videos and
you know snowflakes gonna snowflake type
[ __ ]
well yesterday when Gabe Sanchez was
putting up the bonehead of the weak pull
on Twitter because Gabe Sanchez is the
one who puts the poll up on Twitter so
when you see that poll come up on
Twitter that's the work of
my co-host Gabe Sanchez he noticed he
noticed as he was logged in as the
podcast account he noticed
that Christian Walker was in alive
so he's like oh [ __ ] so he sent it to me
I'm like I gotta get in this
[ __ ] and they were whining and
crying in this lot this Twitter space
not alive sorry Instagram is live
Twitter is spaces
and you know who knows what Twitter will
be here in the next week or two but
right now the live component of the
audio is called Twitter spaces
so they were in a space
quote
so we went in the space and they pulled
up Gabe Sanchez first thinking he was me
because Gabe was under the podcast
account
I went in as my account
and then we started talking to these
chuckleheads and they did not they
fought oh they were [ __ ] pissed they
were pissed that I used the word fascist
they [ __ ] hate that word oh my God
they hate that word they [ __ ] hate
being called Nazis so you know what you
should do you should continue every day
every single moment calling them fascist
and Nazis they [ __ ] I mean they protest
that's too much way too much they
protest over that word they were focused
on it they were asking me if Mal Pol Pot
if if Stalin was a fascist I'm like what
does this have to do anything with you
people being fascist well and then the
best part is they went into book Banning
because I said that you know Ron
DeSantis he's a fascist he wants to ban
books down in Florida right we all know
this he's trying to ban Book Fairs not
just books Book Fairs at schools
I don't know if you've been to a
children's book fair where there's
Scholastic books but they're not selling
porno mags at the Scholastic Book Fair
you [ __ ] fascist so anyways
we get around to this book Banning thing
of course they get on the topic
they brought it up of To Kill a
Mockingbird and The Adventures of
Huckleberry Finn course I kept calling
it at Huckleberry Finn and they kept
correcting me you know it's it it's a
thing that these people do
where they think they're smarter than
you are
so I tried to talk which they kept
cutting my mic you know these are the
free speech [ __ ] they kept
cutting my mic off every time I make a
point they cut my mic off cut my mic off
cut my mic off
but when
I asked them what books they wanted to
ban they had a whole [ __ ] list people
I mean they had a whole list but then
they got really [ __ ] upset because I
was like see I told you you wanted to
ban books no no no it's not a ban
so then they tried to change the word it
was it was it was
um
very
very great entertainment last night this
it was fantastic now how it all came to
a close is very interesting to me
um and the reason why
is because I I didn't know who these
people were I had no idea really I mean
we knew who Christian was he actually
left the room before we got to speak
unfortunately because I know I would
have liked to ask him about
um the race in Georgia
I would have really liked to do that
that's the reason why I kind of went
there in the first place but here's the
thing
is that at the at the very end I brought
up Nick Fuentes
I brought up Nick Fuentes
or they let us speak they were talking
about turning points USA which would be
no if you I know you guys have been here
on the show so you know who turning
points USA is it's Charlie Kirk right
they were talking about what turning
points USA event they're going to go to
and all this [ __ ] yeah that's who these
people are
but I brought up Nick Fuentes and
they're like oh we know who Nick is blah
blah blah blah blah you know
and I brought up the fact of what he
said about dictatorship
and why we need a dictator in this
country what he said that [ __ ] day
yesterday
they blew that off
and then I get because these people
couldn't stop talking about genitalia
I'm telling you they're [ __ ] obsessed
with it it's [ __ ] weird they can't
stop thinking about it it is their
entire political personality right now
the the entirety I mean almost 95 of
their entire political argument has to
do with people other people not theirs
other people's genitalia it's [ __ ]
weird
and I kept I kept bringing that up they
kept bringing up dicks and wieners I'm
not [ __ ] you they kept talking about
it the the one when she was talking
about banning books was talking about
Jack and wieners and and and and jerking
off and all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
her mind couldn't think about anything
else
and I kept bringing up that that's what
they were doing and as soon as I
mentioned Matt Walsh
you know Matt Walsh is oh you know if
you watch this show you [ __ ]
definitely know who Matt Walsh is
as soon as I bring up Matt Walsh I mean
immediately
and I start talking about how that
[ __ ] that that sick pedophile is
obsessed with marrying young women
getting young women pregnant he can't
stop thinking about children's genitalia
he can't stop thinking about genitalia
being mutilated this guy's got a problem
they [ __ ] booted me
they kicked me out of the room
as soon as I went after their their
genitalia Overlord
it was something else folks it was
something else but I'm telling you I'm
telling you the thing that got him
pissed off the most was two things two
things got him pissed off the most and
this is what you need to lean into this
is the reason why I'm telling you the
story is because we control the [ __ ]
narrative not them we are the [ __ ]
majority not them we are the ones who
get to control the major The Narrative
about them they do not get to tell us
who we are because they kept saying that
[ __ ] oh well you wanna you wanna do this
and you want to do that to Children I'm
like what that your party and your party
this and your party that what the [ __ ]
are you talking about man I don't want
to take consent away from parents you're
talking about taking consent away from
parents you are you're wanting to tell
parents what they can and can't do
with their [ __ ] children what books
they can have their children read
you're the ones who are trying to
control people
and that was the point of the Nick
Fuentes clip that I brought up and then
I brought up the Matt Walsh stuff and
that really pissed him off when I when I
called Matt Walsh a pedophile
I mean I don't know if he is or not but
[ __ ] Matt you got you got some weird
[ __ ] going on
when all you can [ __ ] talk about is
impregnating teenage girls and
concentrating on other people's
genitalia especially children's it's
[ __ ] weird [ __ ]
and we control that narrative
we do
they don't get to [ __ ] hate without
being held accountable for it folks
they do not get to hate
without being held accountable and we
must hold them accountable
we did on Tuesday and we're gonna
continue right here on this show
we're gonna continue
I've got a guest on Monday I was
supposed to get Dr Rachel bittickoff run
today
um again she's just so busy with
everything going on trying to finish up
these countings with these elections and
helping some of these uh these places
and get everything straight so Rachel Dr
Rachel bidikoffer is very busy I think
she's going to come on on Monday so I'll
have her on Monday I also have
uh the surfs on Monday
you guys know the Surfs we we're going
to have them on
um and talk about this Matt wall stuff
because they've done extended Research
into not just Matt Walsh himself but
also the documentary that he did where
it's a transphobic documentary where
Matt Walsh can't figure out what a woman
is so he's got to run around the entire
[ __ ] country the entire world trying
to figure out what a woman is because he
can't [ __ ] figure it out
so we're gonna have them on the show
but as soon as I brought up Matt Walsh
these right Wingers booted me from that
Twitter space Oh my God [ __ ]
snowflakes kicked me and I was like look
I I enjoyed this this was fun this was
fun watching you guys lose your mind
when I say the word fascist I mean I say
it I used to say the [ __ ] word and
they just go berserk I mean they're ah
you [ __ ] what's a fascist and
then
the other thing that they do is they're
like Define fascism
so you dust off the old dictionary and
give them the definition they're like
that's not the definition I'm like you
didn't Divine it I'm like I told you the
[ __ ] definition what do you want from
me I don't know what you want from me I
told you what the [ __ ] definition is
I told you what I think it is
they're insane they're insane and let's
let's go to in some insane [ __ ] on the
shitless Roundup wow Twitter still
exists let's round up the Tweety tweets
and the trendy Trends start to count
down
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
the [ __ ] list
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show we have
reached the part where we round up all
the Tweety tweets and trendy Trends here
is um I found this on true social now
everyone's been talking about uh Donald
Trump losing his mind on true social
where he's admitting to federal crimes
election interference and
he's going after the new party leader
Ron DeSantis because Rhonda Santos
appears to be the new party leader the
Triumph
um
but this one I found very interesting
now this is just one of many that I
pulled right and this is more important
than the [ __ ] the tweets or truth
whatever they're called on fraud social
over there
this this is way more important this is
why they [ __ ] lost on Tuesday okay
this is [ __ ] why
because they're absolutely batshit crazy
and this guy is the Cheeto dust q and
honor here and I said Republicans trying
to figure out why they're red wave [ __ ]
the bed this is a post from an account
over on uh fraud social at God
underscore bless underscore Trump I'm
not [ __ ] you that's real
and you can see here it says Donald J
Trump re-truth
which that doesn't even make sense it
should just be like repost I don't know
what the [ __ ] this true stuff is really
stupid
um obviously
I mean let me see if I can pull this up
better here there we go okay so if you
look at it here this is what this is
it's just an image this account at God
bless Trump
um posted just an image it's a meme
and it says the storm is coming of
course and down here at the bottom it's
hard to see but it says wwg one wga
which is where we go on we go all that's
the Q Anon [ __ ]
right that's the Q Anon oath or code or
whatever the [ __ ] it is and the storm is
coming is their little thing that they
think I I don't know maybe it wasn't a
red wave it was supposed to be a storm
and they got the
the the forecast wrong I don't know
there's also a 17 down here in the
corner I'm sure that [ __ ] means some
kind of queuing on [ __ ] I don't know
though I have no idea the best thing is
he's looking up in the sky right but
look here
look right here there's a there's a cue
the Republican applicants are on Fox
[Music]
they're all over the [ __ ] universe
trying to [ __ ] figure out why they
lost
on on Steve bannon's show on Charlie
Kurt show Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh they
can't [ __ ] figure it out
look [ __ ] this is why they lost
right here
this guy is full on Q Anon
and we watched the clip from election
night from Tuesday the midterm where
Donald Trump says and I think it was
news news Nation I'm not sure
what this station is I don't know if
it's it's probably going to turn out to
be another Trader News Network
anyways because they had Donald Trump on
but anyways um he was on the nation news
nation and um
he said out loud
that if
his candidates win he gets all the
credit if they lose it's all on them
right he's not to be blamed for anything
and again this goes back to the
political Capital thing I was talking
about earlier where he's got an
political capital and he doesn't have it
but this is where he's spending it is
right here in this stupid [ __ ] meme
where he's reposting Q Anon memes of
himself he believes this [ __ ]
he believes this garbage
and his supporters because their minds
are so [ __ ] hypnotized
by his dumb ass
they're deluded by it
and the rest of America is [ __ ] sick
and tired of it
there's no better race to look to
than uh the Shapiro mastriano race
that race alone is One race you could
look to and go holy [ __ ]
mastriana was full Q Anon full [ __ ] Q
Anon
when we showed the video uh last week of
him and his wife at a press conference
where they were talking about Jewish
people and going back to Israel and all
kinds of crazy [ __ ]
full-on [ __ ] Q Anon
and he got his ass handed to him now JD
Vance not a little bit he played around
played footsie with the Q Anon stuff
and Tim Ryan had a difficult time really
pinning him down as Q Anon
maciano lost JD Vance not so much going
on
didn't lose
Kerry Lake holy [ __ ]
she's the queen of the Cuban honors
frankly
looks like she's going to get beat by
Katie Hobbs who you know love hate Katie
Hobbs Katie Hopps did not run a good
race folks she did not
I didn't say that into a microphone at
the time because I didn't want to get
you guys discouraged but Katie Hobbs did
not run a good race and I don't know how
good a governor should be but I do know
one thing she's going to be a hell of a
lot better Governor than Carrie Lee
could ever dream of
if she just [ __ ] shows up two days a
week
because of this Q Anon stuff this is why
this country voted these people down
and and said no we're not gonna have the
crazy we don't want the [ __ ] crazy
that is why they didn't have a red wave
they are plagued by this it is a [ __ ]
disease Liz Cheney even said it in this
January select hearings
that is is a [ __ ] disease that has
riddled their party
with a complete mind [ __ ]
and the country knows it the country
knows it
they know it gen Z knows it women know
it
and if you're gonna give power to people
who are completely delusional especially
people who are hell-bent on taking away
your [ __ ] rights
it's not gonna go well
so the country said no and that is why
that is why this morning this guy is
losing his [ __ ] mind that's why there
was no Red Wave that's why it is a
possibility even to this moment
that that the Democrats will still take
the house by one seat
with the Colorado q and honor losing
herself Lauren bobert
it's not complicated to understand it
really isn't but I wanted to show you
guys that again
everyone was posting where he was
freaking out right where he's just
[ __ ] freaking out
but really that doesn't tell the story
that's just the result of what happened
right
to know what actually happened you got
to go down and look at his other [ __ ]
post because he truly
truly is
um on the same way wavelength as Genie
Thomas and believes every single bit
of this Q Anon stuff here is um we're
gonna have one race there's a runoff um
and it it happens immediately
because this uh election is going to
happen very quickly in the runoff in
Georgia in a senate race if if uh if no
one receives at least 50 percent it
automatically goes to a runoff to the
top too which obviously or Warnock who
got the majority of the votes and
Herschel Walker which Herschel Walker is
going to lose this badly but but this
clip here is hilarious I mean it's
funnier than [ __ ] [ __ ] so I want to
show you this clip this is from Jesse
Waters and Fox News you know Jesse
Watters we showed yesterday because he
was he was crying in his milk because
women won't marry him
um so let's let's watch here watch Ted
Cruz's head as Herschel Walker is puking
up his words out watch this because he's
a hypocrite and being a pastor I say
this how can he keep the almighty old to
the almighty God and he'd keep it for
them he hadn't kept it for neither
nobody so that proves the type of man he
really is all right so Cruz you're the
lead blocker here you're gonna have to
open up some holes for Herschel what
you're gonna have to open up some holes
for Herschel that's the quote I guess I
mean when you got a guy just absolutely
puking up word salad on national TV and
Ted Cruz you see Ted Cruz he's like yeah
yeah yeah whatever he's saying I I don't
know what the [ __ ] he's talking about
but yeah yeah yeah
it's crazy ass [ __ ] okay here here's
another one on Fox News
um freaking out let's see oh yes this is
uh you guys know who Mark Elias is Mark
Elias is a is a great attorney in this
country he does he does marvelous work
protecting our elections
um and election Integrity he knows a lot
about it he's probably the top expert in
the entire country and Laura Ingraham
the Nazi here is [ __ ] mad that he's a
Democrat [ __ ] pissed that he believes
in democracy and that he's really good
at what he does but what she says here
it only makes me really want to like
have a beer with Mark and hang out with
Mark it doesn't it doesn't skew me away
from him makes me want to hang out with
him listen to this [ __ ] Republicans
though come on they need their own
version of Mark Elias he can complain
about him but he's pretty successful
maybe we want someone who's not quite as
slimy but nevertheless we need someone
like him
oh they're super jealous aren't they
super jealous
and Mark Elias's pro-democracy and he's
damn good at it hmm seems kind of funny
let's go back I got another video and
I'm just going down the timeline here
real quick uh because we're uh we're
gonna be doing bone end of the week here
soon and I think gay Sanchez is going to
join us here soon this is a video from
uh Herschel Walker
um from the runoff it's this is the same
tent I believe that they were just
having the interview with Jesse Waters
the guy who wants women to marry him but
they won't here is uh here's Hersha
Walker and Ted Cruz pay attention here
to the very beginning when Herschel
Walker's on stage it really feels like
the dude thought that he wasn't gonna
have to do any more of these watch
foreign
[Applause]
so he's not very enthused right like
there's not a lot of enthusiasm there
from Herschel Walker now one thing
everyone kept pointing out when I was
when I played this let me mute this who
gives a [ __ ] if they're cheering
um it's all fake anyways watch watch his
watch the crowd here look look at the
crowd is there can you figure out
um like a a certain thing about all
these people
I don't know I just there seems to be a
theme
with the crown here there's Herschel
Walker again at the beginning of the
video he's not enthused about being
there look at this crowd can you figure
out what the
what they all have in common it really
seems like
they don't have something I don't know
maybe it's just maybe I'm just crazy
here but um
they're all they're all white that's
that's the thing every last one of them
it's really kind of weird
um here is here's a great
and post you know Patriot takes the
account Patriot takes on on Twitter as
long as Twitter's still alive here
um they posted this this picture of
Laura Loomer you know who Laura Loomer
is she's the she's the one who lost in
Florida and was crying remember oh she
was [ __ ] bawling her eyes out
um this is Laura loomer's telegram
um and this is what she's saying
again this inviting is delicious and we
should encourage it not only should we
encourage you we should actually take
the narrative and spend it on them and
just dump on them every single day every
[ __ ] day you gotta dump on them
just like you did with this election
remember what you did with the election
where you were talking about issues and
helping people determine whether it was
a good decision to vote you got to do
that the same thing
same thing for 2024. well and some of
these races in 2023 but here is here's
the wedge that you drive uh Laura Loomer
and she's a full q and honor
right that's why she she worships at the
altar of trump King q and honor
she posts this on on telegram she says
DeSantis is going to file against Trump
in the next few weeks I don't know what
the hell if she knows that or not which
actually that's what I prefer
you should prefer it too as
pro-democracy people we should prefer
that these guys get in the race early
and start fighting each other that's
what they should do now DeSantis is
going to file against Trump in the next
few weeks again she probably doesn't
even know any of that [ __ ] she says you
heard it here first which again now
she's confirming
that she doesn't know and guess who his
political team consists of question mark
Paul Ryan Jeb Bush and Mitt Romney well
[ __ ] you talk about a bunch of
bunch of goddamn liberals
what
surprise she says
you got played by DeSantis so Laura
Loomer is still on the Trump train she
has not switched yet
and if you look at the uh if you look at
the reactions down here they're really
um the ratio is uh is funny
um obviously her her majority of her
support
is in the Trump train right they're
still in the Trump train but there's
some defectors here if you really take a
look
and this is not going well for Trump
that's why he's freaking out again
because DeSantis soaked up any political
capital
that he may have gained from this from
this red wave that didn't happen
and the only Red Wave quote unquote
what's the one that Ron DeSantis put
together in Florida by gerrymandering
okay let's go back to the timeline here
and it dude
oh have you guys seen the Elon Musk yet
holy sh I know you guys don't like to
talk about Twitter that much you have to
talk about politics but [ __ ] this Elon
Mustang has a little bit to do with
politics
have you seen this
this blue check mark thing holy [ __ ] it
backfired
massively on on Elon Trump and really I
gave Elon and I've said this uh many
times on the show since he acquired
Twitter
I gave him way too much credit
way too much credit I really thought
Elon Musk was going to be smart enough
to back out of that deal just pay the
[ __ ] fine pay whatever he had to pay
to make sure that Twitter
stayed public and he didn't buy it I
really thought he was going to be smart
enough to do that I gave him way too
much credit
this guy has destroyed destroyed Twitter
in a matter of days absolutely destroyed
it now I sent this back when he started
firing the CEO
Twitter was barely profitable folks
barely it's a very unique platform it's
part of our daily life now and the
reason why is because the news cycle is
basically driven by it that's why we
surf the Tweety tweets and trendy Trends
here
is because it is
it is the news that's what it is that's
where the journalists live that's where
the reporting lives it lives there
that's where everything the
notifications get dropped immediately
now
Elon Musk
decides that he's going to give anyone
and everyone who play pay eight bucks
a blue check right
you know this it was 20 originally and
then he had to change it to eight
because Stephen King didn't want to pay
20 so
Elon pulls a figure out of his ass eight
dollars and that's what he runs with
I doubt he did any market research at
all when he came up with that number at
all none
so if you pay 7.99 you can get you a
blue check right now it has to be a
verified account and how you're
verifying it is with a bank account
right like a debit card
so apparently what is happening is
um they're these stolen credit card
numbers they're using these credit cards
to verify the account and get the
account
um set up so the blue check account set
up
and then what they're doing is they're
selling these and they're and people are
grabbing them and they're using them to
trick people on Brands like National
corporate Brands some other stuff too
some politicians have started to leak
into the mix there was one that was
posing as Ron DeSantis it was fantastic
um but they're really it it seems like
to me
and this is just just me looking at what
is happening and who's doing it and how
it's affecting his bottom line I
actually think that this is an operation
against Elon
what do I mean by that I actually think
this is a malicious operation that is
designed to take down the Elon Musk at
this point I think what happened was is
there are is a group or a group of
people I don't know if it's Anonymous I
don't know who it is
but I believe that this is an operation
against Elon Musk is that someone saw an
opportunity to absolutely destroy him
because this is 44 billion dollars and
not just that this is 44 billion dollars
he has had to sell Tesla stock 4 billion
to keep liquid here the FTC is now
investigating some of these sales that
he's made
um some of the stuff that he's doing at
Twitter I I know there's going to be
class action lawsuits on how he fired
some of these employees he's begging
them to come back
um just in the last few days he he [ __ ]
canned the the Twitter safety
um chief officer
and then the chief of sales because
she said something snarky to him
apparently comedy is legal on Twitter
just not act
Twitter like Twitter headquarters
apparently
it's not
it's not done there it's not legal there
this guy is a [ __ ] man baby this guy
is a man-child he has way too much
[ __ ] money
way too much money which means way too
much power is the problem
and that's why I'm like wait a second
again
I gave Elon way too much credit when I
thought that he would back out of the
deal right I thought he would pay any
amount of money there was to not buy
Twitter because it was not word 44
billion not only that it's it was not
not going to work out well for him
he's a [ __ ] idiot
he can barely hold together Tesla who
that which is very profitable
and SpaceX which runs off our money
government contracts for these [ __ ]
dildo Rockets to go into space
now I believe it could possibly be an
operation now some of it isn't it's just
a bunch of trolls right it's just trolls
having fun you know getting a verified
account [ __ ] with [ __ ] with people
on on Twitter we've done that before
here
I mean with this whole Rhonda santis uh
Donald Trump thing you guys remember a
few months ago is Gabe Sanchez made a
fake uh Trump announcement and he called
Rhonda Ron DeSantis gutless Rhonda
santlers Ron DeSantis
called him gutless
and and everyone's like oh my God you
remember Seth aberson he lost his
[ __ ] mind Seth aberson did a
three-hour Instagram live
on why that was bad for the country
because of parody
yeah it's [ __ ] hilarious that's a
whole nother [ __ ] day and you guys
can go watch the episode where and just
look for the thumbnail Gabe Sanchez
breaks the internet that's the one you
want to go watch
um if you want to hear the story of of
what happened with that statement
but some of this parody
some of this parody is striking at
something more than just funniness and
laughs
and you know getting even or making a
political statement
some of this is way more sinister
and what do I mean by that well
there was one account
that poses Tesla
that we know he would see
and it's basically striking at his own
brand now Tesla's a public company he's
a CEO of
he just sold a bunch of stock which
tanked the [ __ ] stock price he's
[ __ ] everyone at Tesla anyone who
owns Tesla I would out now [ __ ] that
[ __ ] and I'm not a stock person I don't
know anything really about the stock
market much as far as buying selling
trade and all that [ __ ] but I wouldn't
[ __ ] own Tesla stock if you gave it
to me because that [ __ ] is out
of his mind but it's unclear whether he
has super votes on the board like
through family members or friends
and rather they would keep him as CEO
but one thing is for sure the guys
running out of liquid cash
it's one thing for sure the guy does not
have liquid cash
and it seems like if someone's gonna run
an operation against him it's to destroy
the Twitter brand which would absolutely
evaporate 44 billion hours and it's not
his money it's his investors money
which you have to understand
that breeds to his competence
of a CEO or running a company or buying
a company or have anything to do
with the corporate environment of a
company that's worth 44 billion or
supposedly worth 44 billion
like to me
this blue check ambush
that has been happening some of it seems
like to be a strategic operation against
Elon Musk
now I I I don't have any proof other
than it's destroying him and he's
playing right into it like he is and
again some people have said that that
Elon Musk is trying to intentionally
destroy Twitter which and you know I I
mean that may be
that may be but what what what's the
[ __ ] is the point to smash up Twitter
with a hammer it doesn't matter if
social media is going to live on past
Twitter
in other words the marketability of
Twitter is going to live past Twitter
you're not going to get rid of the
market of Twitter I mean you may get
we're rid of Twitter itself am I right
Gabe Sanchez here and you're not I mean
you may get rid of Twitter itself but
you're not going to get rid of the
marketability of Twitter something's
going to fill that space to fill the
yeah but we talked about last night I'm
talking about how this might be an
operation on anyone
right yeah so it very well could be I
mean obviously we won't know but uh
there could be a coordinated effort
coordinated effort to uh manipulate the
verification system that was implemented
so I you know who knows if it was
originally done that way obviously the
idea was uh
awful but I mean it's plain to see what
the vulnerability of it is right right
and I mean it would be easy to attack
his 44 billion dollar investment just
knowing that right and so like you know
I think for someone who goes in with 44
billion you've obviously got a certain
amount of investment in there
your own ego and you want to be right
and every time he's done something so
far in the last two weeks keep in mind
this has been like 14 to 16 days that
he's actually had the company so in a
very small amount of time he has done a
lot of terrible things in terms of
running the company because even as of
yesterday
uh they said that there was talks of
going into bankruptcy right and so
you've got a guy who takes over this
company fires the board fires execs
fires 50 percent of the the company in
the U.S fires I thought I said 70 in
India
and you got guys you guys 100 in South
Africa I think or somewhere I I believe
they shut down the entire office yeah
they are uh
they are pushing to cut costs across the
board and try to make as much money and
yesterday the announcement was in all
hands that we want to have 50 of our
Revenue coming from Twitter blue the
paying for paying the eight dollars for
the verification package is that even
possible this is a man I don't know
that's so that's the thing like I mean
like I guess anything's possible but it
it all comes down to what is the
marketability of that feature right am I
paying eight dollars for something more
than a badge like what am I getting out
of the badge and obviously the way that
you know Elon is trying to
to kind of like maneuver this is he
wants to say if you're not verified then
we're going to suppress your tweets
right so again
for a guy that's all for free speech
he's saying if you have if you pay
then I will ensure and guarantee that
your stuff is put to the top right
if you don't pay well that's too bad for
you and no one will see your [ __ ] so
that's the that's the game he's playing
so free speech is actually it's a paid
speech is really what it is right and so
you've got a guy that buys a company for
44 billion he's got 13 billion dollars
in debt with with uh banking
institutions he's got to pay back about
a million and a half by April he just
sold 3.95 billion in terms of stocks uh
from Tesla so at some point as this
company goes down and as Tesla goes down
someone's got to stop him and I'm
assuming it would probably come from
Tesla if I had to imagine I don't know
what his voting rights are if he has
like a a super uh uh like share or and
vote right yeah I was saying that
earlier is rather family members friends
but he has to convince those people that
this thing is and obviously like that's
everyone's money I mean obviously you
know they've gone from
you know a small amount I mean before
the pandemic I think the stock was like
a hundred and something and then as the
pandemic uh Rose over the last two years
it was you know an obscene amount I mean
the the name that many people have for
these people are called Tesla
Tesla to Tesla millionaires teslaires I
think is what it's called but basically
teslaires I think is the nickname and
it's basically people who made millions
of dollars by just having an investment
in Tesla during the pandemic and so that
that is uh as a shareholder and as a
board member you would feel like hey we
got to stop this thing before he [ __ ]
you know blows the car up you know so
because as soon as he as soon as he sold
all that stock the other day because
he's got to have liquid cash here right
if they [ __ ] tanked and it just
[ __ ] tanks and it's also and who
knows like I don't know if he puts that
money in he's like look I gotta I gotta
make money back on this in some way and
so he's trying to take out money to pay
and cover these expenses he's cutting
the budget he's cutting whole teams I
mean you've got the guy who was his in
many ways his right hand man that was
the head of safety and privacy at
Twitter who was in all these
conversations who was backing Elon up
and saying yep yep yep this is all good
we haven't changed he was on the calls
with the advertisers he was on the call
with the advertisers all of this stuff
uh he was he was pushing and he'll be
saying this is good Elon knows what he's
doing this and that blah blah blah then
we find out yesterday he was like yo I'm
out peace I'm done he resigned he
retired he fired his uh chief of sales I
guess she she said some kind of snide
remark to him and he fired her I mean
Again comedy is legal on Twitter it's
just not legal act yeah Twitter Elon
cannot take a joke and it's why exactly
it is exactly why when uh people were
you know again at first it was just
joking around and they were like we're
gonna buy these Twitter Badges and we're
gonna impro or celebrities were going to
or personalities we're going to use the
badge as a way to goof on Elon Musk and
they were like I'm Elon Musk you know
blah blah
where he suspended Kathy Griffin he's
suspended a few others for doing it yeah
a ton of people and so because he
couldn't take a joke and then he was
like the name is the word parodies got
to be in the not just in the bio but
also in the name and it's like it
doesn't have to be in the bio it just
has to be in the name like this guy
cannot get a hold of himself he's
[ __ ] losing it because people are
joking making fun of him I mean look but
but that's why last night when I
messaged you I said because we were
looking at because they reinstituted the
gray check mark last night right yeah
because something came across because
they're I mean if you go on Twitter
right now and you're down in the lobby
like in the home in your home page there
is an ad every three [ __ ] tweets
because he because I would imagine and I
don't know the numbers on it but I would
imagine they're cheap as [ __ ] and the
inventory is really high right now like
you're able to imprint your brand on
Twitter right now for probably next to
nothing like literally if you want to
get your message out there right now it
is probably cost you not a God damn
thing to get on Twitter I would imagine
because he's selling it for whatever he
can sell it for and he is piling on the
ants
um if you go look at the feed now what I
noticed was is all of a sudden that that
great check mark came back that's an
official I'm like whoa what the [ __ ] and
it seemed to only be now I haven't
updated my app and the reason why is
because everyone said you have to update
your app to see the new check marks I'm
like well [ __ ] that they don't mean
anything anyways yeah I don't want to I
don't want to update so I don't have to
see them that's yeah you don't have to
because what what they did was so they
made an update that was last week and
they were like uh if you don't want to
update to see it because I am not seeing
them I thought well you sent me a
screenshot last night and I had no no no
no the blue checks the people who paid a
verify through the Twitter blue I have
not updated I have not done an update so
I can't see them and it may be because I
don't update Twitter that often well
here's here's what I've seen it though
is uh I mean that might be the case I
don't know uh they they might have just
been able to reuse that area of real
estate that was like you know candidate
for this seat or person who's arrested
exactly did that and that's what they're
doing right right and so so I don't know
in terms of like I would imagine what
happened was when they released the
latest well I don't know if it hasn't
been update but when when I release the
code and an update last weekend that
wasn't people like oh it's coming it's
here right some people had access some
people didn't have access so basically
what happened is they're talking about
to the Twitter blue verified check right
right okay so basically what they did
was they released this code and it
basically said here's the functionality
of this code but what it allows them to
do is have it ready to go in the app so
they don't have to update the app again
I have a flag it's called a feature
probably need to go update my amp but
here's here's the thing here's here's
the reason why I we we got to stay on
top of this story is because if this is
an operation against Elon Musk because
Elon Musk is really not a threat because
he's some sort of smart Evil Genius he's
a dumb [ __ ] everyone knows that right
now and that really is the threat of
Elon Musk is that the guy has a shitload
of money a shitload of wealth and he can
destroy things with his money and really
honestly it feels like I don't know this
for sure and maybe we should try to
track down some evidence of this
um maybe we get the band journalist
involved or some real journalist real
real actual journalists not people
posing as journalists through Anonymous
accounts but real journalists I think
what we should do is we should
um investigate if this is an operation
because a lot of it's goofing right like
you said a lot of it's goofing yeah but
I think maybe the operation knows that
that's going to happen
but they're really striking at his
marketability and it is destroying I
mean like if even if Twitter was worth
let's say 44 billion dollars which it
was not
within a two-week period this guy has it
has I don't know what the evaluation is
today I mean it's going to be hard to
tell because it's now private but I
would imagine he probably couldn't sell
this [ __ ] thing for 10.
because here's the thing it's
if you had all of the uh existing assets
and when I when I say access assets I'm
grouping in Talent you know head count
all that stuff like the people who are
there who are actually running the right
the way the platform is running before
he destroyed right exactly if you've got
certain execs and this and that like if
those if those are still in place yeah
you could probably sell it maybe you
would take a loss but you could probably
get back what you most of what you paid
the problem right now is that he has
lost he's fired his board he's lost 50
percent plus employees
um he has really [ __ ] up with morale
of existing people who are there because
they're like dude who's safe I don't
know if I should be here anymore I don't
know if I can be here anymore you know a
lot of employees who are fired were like
holy [ __ ] thank God put me on my [ __ ]
misery like even in the week that they
were there where they were stressing out
if I was in the same room as Elon that
would be the feeling I have just put me
out of my [ __ ] misery and I I know
we're going to talk a little bit more
about you on on the uh the [ __ ] or the
uh the bonehead of the week because I
would almost bet that you put him in one
of those spots but here I want to show
this video last night we were in a uh I
was telling the audience earlier that we
were in a oh the one where they kept
muting us yeah they kept muting me they
were like freedom of speech and they
they were like wiener weiner dick dick
dick yeah they were talking they were
they wave your ear in your face they
were saying all kinds of crazy as
someone else who was on on I wish they
didn't they didn't record it so they
didn't which we were like [ __ ] we really
wanted to be disappointed but the thing
we'd be able to pull the audio back I
know but the funny thing about it was as
soon it was one there was one guy who
was like [ __ ] obsessed with talking
about older men shaking the way he said
it was like are you okay with older men
shaking their junk in front of kids
faces like what like no something
happened maybe something happened to
that maybe I was like I don't know what
this has to do with Huckleberry Finn I'm
very like literally at that moment when
he kept saying that we were I was
talking about Huckleberry The Adventures
of Huckleberry Finn and the n-word in
Huckleberry Finn and trying trying to
put some coherent thought into this
Twitter space but they were not having
it they wanted to focus and the best
part is is when they were like we're not
Banning books and I'm like okay what's
the list of books you want to ban though
she's like this one this one this one
this one this one it's not they're like
it's not literally right it's not
Banning well they're like we're
restricting access and then one guy was
like oh so what happens if it's like is
it Banning alcohol if you want to give
if you don't want to give it to a baby
and then so then you're like oh so we're
for government regulation now right does
that mean that you guys want to just
walk into it they just walked into it
and really the conclusion was I asked
him about Nick Fuentes and they actually
floated the idea that this was in
Nicholas's
yeah
um
um his what was it telegram yeah and
they're like you're featured they're
like some guy came in from [ __ ]
Newsmax and was like which he was he is
at new he is from Newsmax that's well
that's what's that's what somebody said
on the call last night I don't know
here look if anyone wants to know it
just imagine a just imagine a [ __ ] I the
way I told it to Tony this guy came in
last night and he started yelling and
and trying to because here's the thing
they did not approach any of the things
that were said as legitimate what they
did was they tried to make light of it
they were like oh that's racist and this
they were trying to yeah they were
calling they were calling me races yeah
they were like when when you called him
out for uh muting you they were like
whoa whoa whoa don't be so anti-semitic
and that's when you know that the other
side isn't genius I just now got that I
couldn't figure that out when they were
saying it oh yeah what they're saying is
now what they're saying is they're
they're the Jewish media in that
scenario is that what they're saying
there's no no they're well what they're
saying is yeah they're the Jewish media
because they because they called me
Kanye at one point
they were like talking about I'm like
trying to stay unmuted in the call what
happened was they said when when you're
like hey look can you stop muting me can
I talk like are you gonna let me talk
what happened to the First Amendment and
they're like yeah yeah talk talk
and when you called them out they were
like whoa don't be so anti-semitic so
that was a that was a dig it was a joke
they were making about Jewish people
controlling the media and then when you
continue to talk they were like whoa
cool at Kanye don't go so anti-semitic
so that again that is when you know when
you are having a attempting to have a
conversation or a debate with someone
who is on the right they will not take
it seriously they will be disingenuous
and they will use ad hominems they will
do all of these things or straw man
arguments they will do all of these
things to try to uh make their argument
legitimate and it's and that that's what
happened last night so we're in this
call laughing hysterically because each
time they mute us or they they mute Tony
in that time and they were like oh okay
okay okay listen listen we're doing this
thing we're saying this thing we're
testing the theory all it's like just
accept the fact and then they were going
through a list of like is this person a
fascist yes this person of fashion was
Mal of fast well because that's what
that's where it really kicked off where
I really pissed him off is when I call
Rhonda Santos a fascist right when I did
that I mean they lost their [ __ ] they
were like give us the definition of
fashion and I did I told them what I
think it is and I told them what the
definition was they didn't listen and
they're like and they and the other
thing too is like they know
the definition of fascist right you know
what fascism is right and they would
know because here's the thing they know
exactly they bring up these people that
they know are fascists and they want to
check against to check your logic right
Stalin and the one thing that they said
this is hilarious because that I know
got so mad right she got pissed off well
and I want to show you a an actual uh
self-proclaimed fascist here Nick
Fuentes which I brought up in the chat
and they were like oh yeah we know Nick
like they they really like Nick yeah so
and I'm gonna show you the the clip here
yesterday of Nick Fuentes he started
trending on Twitter of what he said
about the midterms and it's the thing
that I've been telling you that they
want but um when I called Rhonda Santos
a fascist they they doubt protest way
too much like they were super offended
that I even said the word fascist and
then they started talking about
genitalia and then they kicked me out of
room and I talked about Nick Fuentes and
Matt Walsh oh they got real mad about
that we [ __ ] booted me they and not
only did they boot me they closed the
entire room yeah they're like okay
another room it was probably on for like
another minute where they well they they
thought that they booted us
they thought they booted us or at least
they thought they took away the
microphone yeah they took away the mic
so they're like you can't speak and you
can't speak You're shut off you're just
listening so what was funny is they
think by doing that they booted us so we
sat in the room for another minute or so
before they closed it down why they
tried to wrap up while they were trying
to wrap up and joking about it and then
they openly were like oh man do you
remember when you made that racist
comment about the big ears that was
[ __ ] funny bro and it's like
wait I are you what okay they're weird
they're weird man they're weird but I I
we need to find out if they if Nick
Fuentes is the one on telegram that was
promoting that right live or that yeah
Twitter space I call it a live because
I'm so used to like tic-tock and
Instagram but it's I'm just assuming
that that the that the uh the douche
uh prop I'm assuming played lacrosse in
high school probably has a
is that the Newsmax guy you're talking
about it yeah
some basically for anyone who obviously
doesn't know what happened this guy came
into the chat at the very end and was
like he was one of those people who he
paid for a blue check mark I was like
I'm verified I couldn't see any of their
blue checks so he had a blue check mark
and he was like I'm verified and all
this [ __ ] uh but he came in started
yelling and was like oh yeah well I bet
you love about John Quincy Adams and
daughter how this and that and the
Freemasons and you love what they say
and I was like dude where are you going
with this man
he's a bonehead and you know the best
part is I kept promoting the podcast in
the [ __ ] Twitter space I was like
yeah on our show on the podcast we do it
every every weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 just like I do
here like I was promoting it they're
like hey stop money and promote his show
um here but let's show Nick Fuentes here
because I brought this clip up in this
Twitter space right I brought it up in
this Twitter space yeah they knew it
their their response was flat but let's
listen to Nick fuentes's own words here
he's a holocaust denier he's a Nazi he's
America First Nazi let's see what he has
to say about the 2022 midterm you got to
recognize the fact that this is a
Godless country
I hate it it's immoral it's wrong it's
heinous it's evil
but this is an evil Country and this
country will surprise you with how evil
it is and that's why you've got to get
this out of your head that there is some
silent majority Cavalry that's going to
come out of the woods and save us at the
last minute it's not
when we meet the left on the battlefield
and they outnumber us like five to one
that's it
so I want to stop it there because he's
going to get to the good part here of
what he really thinks and why why he
wants Republicans to be dictators um but
here's the thing is you notice the
language uh meet the left on the
battlefield
um he's really he's really stoking up
his his right-wing trolls as he does all
the time because it's it's more about
um violence and stochastic terrorism
than it is about democracy that it is
about people's voices and you're going
to discover that in the second half of
how Nick went does but I want to be
clear who this [ __ ] is
everyone's seen us play Nick winters's
videos on here yeah this is the guy who
runs the opposition
um every time there's a CPAC you guys
know what CPAC is he runs the America
First pack the AF pack and they usually
do it right across the street or
somewhere really close he's actually
been kicked out of cpax him and his
[ __ ] incel army goes inside and they
cause commotion they kick him out but
Marjorie Taylor green
and several other politicians but
Marjorie Taylor green who is still
elected as a congress person in Georgia
actually has went and spoke at this
guy's events and this guy on video has
said I love Margaret David Green I'm
getting friends with her they're best
buddies him and Marjorie Taylor green
and I and I want that to be very [ __ ]
clear in the front of your mind when you
watch the second half of this video
watch
the point is when you look at these
things like abortion it's popular people
like abortion hate it but it's true and
you can thank the Jewish media for that
abortion's popular sodomy's popular you
know being gay is popular being a
feminist is popular
sex out of wedlock is popular
contraceptives are it's all popular
that's all that's not to say it's good
that's not to say I like that popular
means the people support it which they
do
and uh and it sucks and it is what it is
but that's why we need uh dictatorship
that's unironically why we need to get
rid of all that we need to there it is
folks that's why we need a dictatorship
so basically Nick Flint is the the the
Pied Piper of the in-cell white dude
Army in this country is saying the
reason why we need a dictatorship and
this is why they've been frothing at the
mouth about this for [ __ ] years and
this is the reason why they love Trump
and they've loved Trump because that's
the wet dream of these fascists is for
him to be their leader because he'll
absolutely do anything they tell him to
do yep and that is why they they really
wanted a red wave in this election is so
that they could install a dictator it
was to win the governor's races in
Pennsylvania and Michigan and Arizona
those three races are going to be the
biggest disappointments but not only
that they wanted to win the house big so
they can impeach Joe Biden and Peach
Kamala Harris install whatever speaker
they wanted and have some kind of
delusional [ __ ] thing that doesn't
exist where they install a president of
the United States from the speakership
it really is delusional [ __ ] it's
batshit crazy but it's not surprising
coming from these people right when I
brought this up last night they were
like oh yeah we of course we know Nick
because what the funny part is before we
spoke Gabe they were talking about
turning points USA events and and uh do
they have it all worked out or they got
the luggage do you got your tickets
they're like oh are you speaking one
guy's like well they know what my
speaking fee is so I'll only show for
that and I'm like I'm not gonna do it
and I was like
all right dude you guys really you guys
are little too in your head right now I
mean here's the thing at the end of the
day like you look I mean obviously
today's title is you know party's over
or
um
but I have a feeling like right now Fox
News Murdoch they're [ __ ] on Trump
all this [ __ ] but like
who's to say in six months
that they don't reverse course because
they realize that there's a [ __ ] ton of
these Mega Republicans out there and
they did it on Jan six didn't they yeah
they did it on Jan six and so like the
same [ __ ] on January 6 where days after
weeks after January 6th these
Republicans and the media were like whoa
whoa whoa this is just a step too far
and then they realized oh well a certain
percentage of the country which is a
large group of people oh well they're
[ __ ] they're they're excited why would
we go against what they think and so
that's what I think like right now
they're calling this out a lot of
language I hear is don't announce right
now take a pause don't do this hold off
take a beat you mean about Trump from
the Republicans yeah yeah and I think a
lot of people there on on on media are
I think many many of them right now are
just kind of fair weather fans they're
looking at what happened and they're
seeing that Trump could not carry what
he said he would right he doesn't have
the leverage right now that he said he
would or that he has and I think that
was you know in hopes who knows I mean
does he still announce that he's running
on Tuesday he might say [ __ ] it I'm
gonna do it because I'm uh you know I'm
a what you know I'm a Maverick yeah I
hope he does too I hope he does but I
honestly think that can be great the
Republican party is going to realize
that there is no path forward without
Trump right this party's got to [ __ ]
implode for that [ __ ] to reset and I
think right now there are too many too
many cogs in this machine that are
pro-trump and if they and they're you
know there may have been enough to say
no for these other candidates but as the
race becomes a national one in a general
election in 2024 there are going to be
more people who deny the election there
are going to be more people who want to
suppress votes these are the there are
more people who want to intimidate
voters these are the tactics that
Republicans can only rely on to win
they're going to do more things where
they want to redistrict 10 years down
the line these are all things that the
Republican party has to rely on because
they don't have anything to offer they
don't have any policies they don't have
any things that'll make your life better
they want to take away your rights they
want to take away the ability for you to
actually challenge them or critique them
if they ever do something that isn't in
your own best interest and so at the end
of the day I really do believe maybe in
six months or seven months or something
like that into 2023 as we lead into this
uh new new uh election cycle I think
honestly what's going to happen is
they're going to change course and
they're going to realize that Trump is
this is a larger than life entity that
they have to stay with I hope you're
right and I hope it's right before Ron
DeSantis announces oh everyone stick
around we are at the bottom of the
second hour we're gonna do bone end of
the week as soon as we get back from
this break sticking around bone of the
week right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back
it's Friday you know what that means
we're in the second hour
bonehead of the week you vote
you decide
we break it down for you
[Music]
phone head of the week and this this
Edition is bound to be the bonehead of
the century oh boy
he is a bonehead
huge huge huge huge everyone knows what
we're talking about huge he ran away
with it really honestly so yeah let's
just get into it I know we're running
short on tonight so let's let's get into
bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week as we do every single Friday
here on the Tony Michaels podcast where
you vote you decide who is the bonehead
of the week and we break it down for you
there's two places you can vote Gabe you
can go to the Tony Michaels podcast
Community page on our YouTube channel
just subscribe and you can go there or
you can go to Twitter as long as it's
still around and Elon hasn't crashed
that [ __ ] at Tony Michael's pod
you can go to Tony Michael's pod and you
can vote on the Tweety tweets as long as
they still exist you know what one of
these days when it does Crash and Burn
yeah we should still just give homage to
Twitter and be like well you used to be
able to yeah you could we can have like
a memorium kind of thing where it would
be past uh boneheads that people have
tweeted or like voted on right and we'll
just have this very like maybe we'll
have like Sarah McLachlan uh or or like
uh instrumental
[Music]
it just it's it's so funny that that he
is such an idiot that he has destroyed
Twitter in a matter of hours really if
you think about the whole if you think
about the whole the whole thing it
really was just a matter of hours where
he tore the whole thing to the ground
well let's get into bonehead because he
is making a special spot here on Bowman
but these are our candidates today Nick
Fuentes Charlie Kirk and Donald Trump
we've already seen some of this
um from the show today but um these are
our candidates for bonetta of the week
we should start with Charlie Kirk
shouldn't we I think that's a great
place to start what did Charlie do to
work his way on bonehead of the week
well it really started I think Monday
definitely on Tuesday Charlie was
freaking out about this Arizona race
because obviously he's a pro Blake
Masters pro carry Lake Pro he lives in
Arizona right like
and it's it's near it's near Phoenix I
believe right right where is where his
headquarters is and I assume that
Charlie Lives you know Arizona secretary
state Secretary of State Mark fincham
all people all election deniers people
who want to control you know Blake
Masters even though he tried to scrub
his website definitely wanted to have a
national ban on abortion uh Mark fincham
spreading conspiracies about the 2020
election even called out during his 60
Minutes interview Carrie lay continues
and her soft focus daytime soap opera
camera
continues to push that Joe Biden does
not win the election [ __ ] lighting
[Music]
the darker lighting means that you can't
see all of the different imperfections
let's say if you have a soft bokeh
effect in the background like she has it
makes the uh the foreground her her as a
subject more appealing and also there is
some sort of like filter like a soft
glow on her so it's like it's not crisp
it's a little it looks like someone put
wax paper over the lens yeah just say
that so that's that is that is what she
does and it's an and it's an attempt to
create this always good looking image so
when you think of Terry Lake you're like
oh yeah she looks good in that image she
looks because it's always the same and I
wouldn't be surprised if like that
studio she's got the same lighting she's
got a really good camera right but
Carrie Lake isn't hard to look at I mean
she's not like hard to look I mean when
you look at her now you're like oh
that's vile and disgusting because she's
a vile disgusting right because the
things that she says it definitely away
from right exactly but like Charlie Kirk
here is hard to look at he's he's kind
of yeah he's kind of fugly I mean I love
it I love the fact that he's got a big
gov sucks thing in the background but
that big gov is the same thing he wants
to use to control women's bodies right
well and all a lot of other things a lot
of yeah exactly but he's got his I voted
sticker here
um and this is Charlie's Charlie's show
here on the trader news network uh real
America's voice and he's I think he's
going to talk about
um some crime that he wants people to
commit let's listen this is this is
close guys to presidential style turnout
it's very close
um and so I encourage everyone that is
out there to still please show up and to
vote
um you have to you know you cannot allow
them to get take you out of line we are
still getting messages from people on
the front lines of everyone on our live
stream and everyone that's watching that
saying Charlie I was in line and then
they told me I couldn't vote that is
illegal film them do not put up with
that this is so he's telling someone is
telling anyone to get out of line well
right but this is this whole stupid
thing they were talking about this last
night in that stupid Twitter space where
they're like oh Philadelphia in Arizona
I'm like okay so show me your court case
that that the attorneys at the RNC are
bringing against these these things and
and they're like well Kerry Lake filed
and Brake mastered filed a lawsuit but
the judge threw it out like okay so but
also that was that was to extend the
voting hours three hours right which
again if we remember how Republicans act
like even in the 2012 election in
Florida Rick Scott was literally
shutting down voting locations I
remember that happening because I used
to work with his daughter so I knew
exactly what was happening at the time
and also confirmation from the daughter
who was like I [ __ ] hate my dad
um
but in Arizona right they're claiming
that people are kicking them out of line
all this stuff and they want an extra
three hours
no one is kicking anyone out of line no
one is doing that the only people who
have done that historically have been
Republicans who say It's Pat it's now
past seven o'clock or whatever the time
is you have to get out of line which is
which is illegal if you're in line by
that time I'll be able to vote and they
say sorry you got here too late or they
say yeah you're good you can go vote
there is a last there is a last person
that's going to vote now the thing that
he's saying though about filming and
taking pictures you cannot do that like
don't do not take pictures inside of a
polling station do not do that that is
not a thing you want to do and if you do
do it do not share them with anyone
don't do that you cannot take pictures
in that area there are people who can
film and they do have some but do not
film you do not have the authorization
the other thing that I think is is crazy
too is here's a clip um from the eighth
right and this is uh this is Charlie
Kirk and the pizza gate guy you know we
watched a video of him yesterday talking
about how he was scared of women who
wanted are men who wanted to be women or
some [ __ ] I don't know these I don't
know I mean they're all insecure that's
really [ __ ] weird but um this here is
um and we're I think we've got um more
of this unmarried women today on bone
end of the week yeah this here is uh
Jack Pete's again I'm not sure who this
guy is over here
um irrelevant right but listen to what
they say this this is gonna go and play
into the clip that we're gonna play of
Nick Fuentes but listen to this about
democracy listen to what they believe
about democracy Pennsylvania judge just
allowed just ruled to allow ballots to
count that are received up to November
14th a week after election day okay this
is what they want this is the allowing
ballots after election day in
Pennsylvania
okay what the judge is actually ruining
on there is is ballots that are
postmarked that were received that are
still coming in because I don't know the
mail is slow what the [ __ ] how can't
these people how can't they well that's
the same thing like the people that were
that were in that uh Twitter space that
we were in yesterday which was a bunch
of for you know again for people just
joining those people were a bunch of
right-wing uh sycophants they love these
people sitting yeah they love Charlie
Kirk they love uh Matt Walsh but in in
there they were like well what you know
when we were bringing up this idea of
like Okay show us show us the the case
show us the proof that you did something
that something happened illegal and
someone filed a motion and they were
like well in Pennsylvania there was this
guy with keys and he left him open the
Dropbox do you see the project Veritas
video
one one you say the word project Veritas
and I'm like okay now I know it's about
now I I definitely know that this is not
to be taken seriously but also if you
were to Google search or DuckDuckGo
whatever you want to use or bing.com you
literally can look this up and it would
get and it's it's been uh disproven and
it said oh no those actually weren't the
ballots or the the box was fixed and
these weren't actually counted or
whatever it might have been I forget but
I can tell you for a fact that what they
were claiming that a guy just left the
keys on this thing
and he just let people do whatever he
wanted that is not what happened these
people are insanity but listen to what
these chuckleheads here say about
democracy let's listen this is what
they're hoping for I think and they just
hired Mark a lot so I don't want I don't
want to get conspiracy theorists here in
Arizona but in general this is what they
want to have happen what they want to
have happen is we implemented these
really good ideas because this is the
best way to vote and then all of a
sudden there's breakdown right and then
a judge comes in and they go oh we're
going to keep we're going to keep
polling places open until next week
honestly they should keep some of these
polling places open in the in some of
these days until the lines they want the
polling places where where their voters
are going to go vote to stay open they
want they want all the Democratic
polling places close I actually I was
talking to my wife about this on
Election Day because when when we went
to vote we went inside and there were
more people that are that are usually
there at the time that we vote on voting
date normally we go in and sometimes
we're the only ones in there because the
time of day that we go we pick a certain
time where we know there won't be that
many people at the polling place that is
assigned to us and I say a sign because
in our state we have to vote at a
certain place we have to go to this
certain place and I was like you know
it's kind of crazy
that that we scan our IDs in Missouri
you have to have your [ __ ] photo ID
that I have to go to a certain place to
vote with my ID like if it's if if it's
so secure with my ID and you're scanning
it to make sure I am who I am and I'm
going to sign the thing shouldn't I be
able to vote anywhere the [ __ ] I want
right I mean you technically can it
would be a provisional ballot well right
but but but the point is is that what
I'm what I'm trying to get at is these
[ __ ] chuckleheads here because I know
what they're about to say about
democracy
um but these chuckleheads here don't
want people who they don't want to vote
have access to the back and that's the
reason why is because they know they're
outnumbered they know they're
outnumbered and the only way they win is
if they stop the people that are going
to [ __ ] say no to them
from boating that is what and listen to
what they say it's proof right here this
is it get taken care of but then that's
it I think that Mason Scottsdale they
should open up for a couple more hours I
just want to say um I just want to take
a moment to to just to just stay how
much appreciation I have for democracy
how much I love democracy and you guys
love we're not at the moment right now
don't you love this constitutional
republic
I love democracy though I just love my
democracy
there you go there you have it and and
of course he's being an ass wipe right
he's being a jackal he's being facetious
here like doesn't really mean it
obviously he's saying they don't want
democracy and Charlie Kirk even confirms
that we are not a democracy right and he
also said like democracy is bad right
you see you also see those Turning Point
USA uh and other lawn uh signs that say
you know democracy is overrated right so
it's one of those things where
you know these people believe oh we you
know we built this country on a
democratic foundation with our founding
fathers and this and that but then when
it actually comes to exercising and
following the rule of law and promoting
and following
democracy they go no no no no we don't
want to actually do that that's unfair
that's [ __ ] it's all a [ __ ]
gimmick it's not really you know but
again it's coming from the people that
are actually trying to get people to not
vote right just like there were people
in in Arizona with guns and body cams
and camelon
like what are you gonna be camouflaged
in a [ __ ] blacktop parking lot you're
great what do you what are you doing
it's nice it's not it's not about
protecting anything it's about stealing
away our democracy is what it's about
again if you really if you really did
believe in a and I'll say it again if
you really did believe in a fair and
free election you would not do these
tactics of suppressing intimidating
denying elections those are all things
that a a liar or a cheat would do if you
know you can't win fairly
you're gonna [ __ ] and moan and complain
about it and say oh well this isn't this
is uh we got to keep this open we got to
do this uh don't there's a there's
non-stop you've got Ted Cruz complaining
about Arizona Tony and I have talked
about this Arizona it is it is it should
be much quicker these these counting
processes right should be quicker right
we should have a better shot we should
know we should know the Colorado Nevada
and Arizona results we shouldn't exactly
but when you've got Republicans like Ted
Cruz complaining about Arizona it's
taking so long do you know who's the
head of the [ __ ] election board it's
a republican the miracle the Maricopa
County election board head is a [ __ ]
Republican so don't come at me with that
[ __ ] of saying oh well it's so
unfair this clearly is rigged are you
there's one Democrat and the the three
others are Republican and the the head
of that board is a republican so if you
ever see someone online trying to [ __ ]
and moan about Arizona and say that it's
a Democrats fault you can easily clap
back and say it's a it's a a
republican-controlled board the head of
the board is Republican it has nothing
to do with being a Democrat it's because
there are certain policies and
procedures that were put in place by
republican-controlled legislators so if
anyone complains about that you could
just clap back and say that it's under
Republican control and Leadership so
well you know they can just [ __ ] off
like our next contestant right yeah
that's true Nick Nick Fuentes can just
[ __ ] all the way off
um because he said some crazy [ __ ] he
said some crazy [ __ ] in the past but I
actually believe that this uh what he
said is not
um that out of step for the Republican
party this is a person who has had
Marjorie Taylor green speak at their
events um he's good friends with
Marjorie Taylor green who is now
re-elected he's made videos where he's
like oh my you know my my friend is
Margaret Taylor green Margaret Taylor
Green's like I did this I didn't know
who these people were yeah right right
you didn't this guy is is best friends
with Paul gozar
um who's a congressman from Arizona uh
an insurrectionist Paul goes is the one
who wanted to overthrow our election I
wonder why after we listened to this
also the one who has shared violent
images of uh AOC right right absolutely
well we know who these people are but
yeah I'm gonna give you a little dose
again of who nifuentes is and their take
on the 2022 midterm let's listen
but it's true and you can thank the
Jewish media for that abortion's popular
sodomy's popular you know being gay is
popular being a feminist is popular
sex out of wedlock is popular
contraceptives are it's all popular
that's all that's not to say it's good
that's not to say I like that popular
means the people support it which they
do
and uh and it sucks and it is what it is
but that's why we need uh dictatorship
that's unironically why we need to get
rid of all
we need to take control of the media or
take control of the government and force
the people to
believe or force them to play by our
rules and reshape the society
and that is what they thought this
election was going to be about that is
what every election is about to them
that's what their ideology is and that's
why Nick Fuentes worked his way on
bonehead of the week I don't know that
we even need to go past Nick's own words
here no to describe what why he's on
bonehead of the week do we nope nope I
mean look they're did it himself he did
he did a great job yeah he did a great
job he he went out and he stumped for
himself and he was excellent and here's
the thing we could go through a long
list of stuff where he's talked about
baking cookies and relating it to uh the
the genocide and Holocaust of Jewish
people the guy is an anti-semite he's a
racist he's a Nazi he is this America
First white nationalist the same things
that Matt gates are a part of Jim Jordan
marjor Taylor green Lauren bobert all of
[ __ ] Rhonda Sands all of these people
all these people in the Republican Party
feel this way they believe in this thing
and that is why even though
you know more louder or loud voices are
saying that you know Trump is is gone
he's got to move away
they're not the group that's actually
representing
this this uh this movement there are
some people talking because they're
trying to save face right now but you've
got these other people that are
re-elected into office that are going to
push this the next handful of years
well thank you Nick Fuentes for giving
us your nomination for bone of the week
we have an alpha cut though every week
we do an alpha dishonorable mention who
is our Alpha cook for this week is it uh
Jesse Waters oh yeah Jesse Waters what
did Jesse what did Jesse do well you
know in a typical Republican misogynist
fashion uh Jesse Waters decided to blame
single women single independent
unmarried women do they have the right
to vote I mean Jesse doesn't want them
to but do they have the right they have
the right to vote and Jesse is upset
that if you're unmarried you're single
that you have the right to vote he
thinks that married women
should if they're married to men I mean
he talks about he says it himself which
is completely asinine but his argument
is married women would understand their
position and vote Republican if we have
more men marrying these unmarried women
then we'd have more Republican votes
well that's what he's showing in this
graphic here in this in this exit poll
you can see it was a Fox news report on
Jesse Waters [ __ ] stupid TV show and
here it shows that um the Republican
numbers and the Democrat numbers and the
one he's focused on more than anything
is the unmarried women here at the top
31 voted for Republicans which actually
it makes me that that floors me that 31
voted yeah four Republicans but 68
percent voted for Democrats right that's
what he's really [ __ ] upset about
here is that 68 of unmarried women voted
for Democrat now I believe this is the
view of Jesse Waters what he's saying
here of course he makes a joke about it
which is a sexist misogynistic joke of
course it's coming from Jesse Waters but
what he's really saying and what the
Republicans are saying about this data
is that
the we should not let unmarried women
vote because they don't have a husband
to tell them who to vote for I really
believe that's like like as soon as as
soon as we found out that Gen X voted in
droves the immediate reason oh yeah
excuse me the excuse is Gen Z we found
out gen Z voted in droves in this
election the first reaction from the
right was don't let them vote and that's
what Jesse Waters is doing here too oh
my God the the unmarried women category
the demographic folks strongly against
because they're not voting for Democrats
I don't believe they're voting against
Republicans taking away their [ __ ]
rights right so so when he sees that
what he's saying is is hey marry get
married up that way you have a husband
to tell you what to do because listen
listen to how he frames it though I'll
I'll let I'll let Jesse be the bonehead
here
also single women are breaking for
Democrats by 30 points
and this makes sense when you think
about how Democrat policies are designed
to keep women single
but once women get married they vote
Republican married women married men go
for Republicans by double digits but
single women and voters under 40 have
been captured by democrats
so we need these ladies to get married
and it's time to fall in love and just
settle down guys go put a ring on it I'm
sure all the guys out there are gonna
capture these unmarried women by
listening to Jesse Waters I mean I don't
know about you but I feel like a lot of
these single
Mega Men are you telling me that this
clip made it it has to make the room
moist when someone I mean look if I were
if I was a woman and I was watching this
clip I would totally merely understand
the misogynistic Viewpoint that Jesse
Waters has to say my only value is to
vote Republican and to do that I need to
marry a man
and the the options out there are just
oh my God it is it is unbeatable it's
crazy right the amount of Republican men
who offer me something of value who
actually take interest in me who
actually care about what I say and what
I believe in oh my God I wonder I wonder
why there's not lines of people lining
up behind or at Fox and he's trying to
marry Jesse Waters after this clip I can
only I mean I only imagine why that is
you know we talked about it yesterday
you've got apps like the right stuff and
all and I want to also keep in mind that
it's the right stuff are the white stuff
I thought
I think I think they wanted to call the
white stuff but then it became the right
stuff but here
here's also what people you remember is
that there have been countless and I
mean countless apps that were pro-trump
Pro Mago Pro Republican dating apps that
were created after Trump was uh was was
elected into office okay there were
literally one there was literally one
with a logo where it's like got like a
golden hair swoop kind of thing over
like uh only trumpers or vote you know
some some CR the names are um very
creative
but all of these apps they shut down
within a matter of months I mean one
maybe lasted a year but all of them shut
down
in no time
because they have the same problem that
the right stuff has any dating app that
is specifically focused especially on
politics but I'm going to specifically
say right wing political uh uh are you
saying their views are toxic is that
what you're I'm saying that when they
when you've got people out there like
I'm looking for just a good
old-fashioned American woman who makes
me dinner and does this blah blah blah
whatever or I have a woman who who knows
her place and knows like Marjorie Taylor
green says that they're of a inferior
gender to men you know you've got Lauren
bobert saying similar stuff all of these
people who go on to these apps they
think that they want they think
they want an actual Republican man
because they're like oh yeah they hold
American values yeah [ __ ] back the
blue all this [ __ ] whatever whatever I'm
an independent woman I will speak my
mind you can't tell me what to do
but as soon as they join they start
having these conversations with these
people and they find out that it's
[ __ ] toxic as [ __ ] they're probably
getting uh you know inappropriate
messages probably way worse than what
you'd probably find in like a bumble or
Tinder or something like that because
hey Free Speech baby we've let the love
[ __ ] Ding Dongs all over this app
and so then they realize that right if
there's anything wrong with ding dongs
to each their own whatever but what I
will say
what I will say is that all of these
right-wing apps fail the right stuff
will fail anytime there is a protron pro
right-wing Republican dating app that is
created it fails in months it is 100
like they're batting a thousand which is
pretty impressive honestly they bat a
thousand at this thing that says no
woman actually within the Republican
party at least wants to date a
republican man especially when they walk
into this dating app party and it's just
a [ __ ] sausage fest because you
realize that the women who were in there
leave and the only people left are men
so the men are just waiting around
[ __ ] so what are you up to what's
going on they're just talking to other
dudes on there
well speaking of speaking of apps that
are about to fail and fail within days
and that brings us to our dishonorable
mention this guy here
second second week in a row is it really
wow he's really [ __ ] it up then oh
well you know he he looked at it last
week and was like how do I how do I do
even worse
like do you think he saw the bone end
and he's like man I really got to make
it on there next week yeah I wanna he's
like these are the only people that are
that are that are sharing my face in a
somewhat positive way but not really
well it happens that way um this is one
of the best I think uh Brit myzealous
from Midas Touch made this uh Meme here
and for my next trick watch as I make 44
billion disappear because that's truly
what he's doing here is he is absolutely
burning cash like a [ __ ] and I
think there was even a meeting that they
had and this is the reason why I I
really felt like he he deserved
dishonorable mention when you said
you're gonna make him DM yeah is because
I guess in this meeting he told them
that hey I'm running out of [ __ ]
money Twitter's Twitter's running out of
cash and bankruptcy is not out of the
question like he said that he's like
it's on the table I'm considering it we
are in a situation because how many days
has he owned this thing though like like
14 14 to 16 days I think because I think
he's going to chat two weeks I yeah I I
want to say he took a look at this [ __ ]
in two weeks the 28th maybe the 26th of
October God so in a 14 to 16 day range
this guy came in 44 billion took the
company private forced people to work
14-hour days to to [ __ ] jam through a
verification uh fix for Bots and trolls
and boy did it work right oh wow it was
something else so that really got rid of
the box and they were like all right
we're gonna launch this before the
election and everyone myself included
was like that's the dumbest [ __ ]
thing I've ever heard then I guess maybe
investors would like maybe want to hold
off or maybe Engineers are like we're
not ready yet we haven't fully tested
this thing that you told us to build in
less than a week and then they [ __ ]
dumped it election night didn't they
they like it was like election like
election night no like it was like
you're like okay now we're gonna do this
yeah they boom they did it so then they
dropped that and then people are like
wait wait wait hold on so anyone can buy
it and then they were like well we're
also going to include a double
verification which is a great check mark
that goes underneath your name this is
just which is dumb as [ __ ] it's so dumb
it's so then within three hours I think
it was they I don't even think it was
three hours they're like oh this is
everyone hates this this is a really bad
idea well and elon's like I killed it so
he kills it now everyone has the
opportunity to become a verified blue
check mark so no one can tell the
difference unless you know to click the
check mark and say oh this person's
subscribed for it so what happens what
happens though when you allow someone to
imitate Brands like big huge corporate
Brands I mean they're worth a lot of
money that would be able to give Elon a
lot of money and add dollars what
happens when you do that they might say
go [ __ ] yourself and then they leave the
platform and they say we're not gonna do
this because you're allowing everyone to
imitate and impersonate us and now we're
losing our brand recognition you've got
Lockheed Martin somebody took over lock
it or not took over the Eli Lilly one I
thought was the most was really damaging
right so that's the thing at first it
was like we're just gonna imitate Elon
Musk and then it shifted into malicious
Bad actors who were saying okay we're
not goofing anymore we're now going to
make ourselves into legitimate companies
and we're going to say really bad things
and you find that Eli that Eli Lily
let's let's show everyone the Eli
because I think it's the prime example
of how how how Elon is going to tank
Twitter now I actually believe it'll
survive in some form or fashion the
question is is can whoever buys it for
pennies on the dollar from Elon because
I think that's where he's going here
whoever acquires it from or whether it's
like venture to capitalist or our actual
um like Jack Dorsey uh takes it
um you know rather he actually buys it
it's unclear at this point but I
actually think someone's going to
acquire it that's where we're at and
then this but the question is can they
revive it um back from where they're at
this yeah I mean like you know if
certain if if everyone wasn't fired and
people didn't quit and all these things
you possibly might be this is okay but
you might possibly be able to recover
this
um knowing how to actually repair the
the damage that's been done this right
here is an example of cause and effect
of what Elon implemented what he decided
he said this is the way that we fix it
this is the way that it's done you guys
got to build it I don't care how long
you have to work you got to get it done
and we need to ship it next week now you
can see you can see that this tweet was
posted at 1 36 p.m I'm not sure what
time zone that is on 11 10. so yeah this
was posted yesterday now if you look at
the top it says Eli uh Lily and Company
with the with the verified check and
then the handle is at Eli and Co and
remember that anyone with a verified
check because of what Elon did they get
one included in a verified column that
people follow on Twitter or interact
with on Twitter and not only that but
they also get surface to the top as a
higher priority so anyone who pays it so
it's going to be boosted more so anyone
who pays eight dollars gets it's a blue
check mark nobody knows to click the
check mark to know what the difference
is between a someone who's actually of
notable kind of status well that would
be the only way to really look at this
tweet and tell because you've got to go
unless you knew unless you knew Eli
Lily's specific handle because some of
the handles are parody and you can tell
they're fake handles but this one
specifically it looks like the Eli Lilly
handle now what the Tweet says is we are
excited to announce insulin is free now
which is insanity because that actually
wouldn't be a bad idea like that
wouldn't be a bad idea right to happen
Eli Lily is not going to do that Eli
Lilly is not going to do that now you
can see the thing that really
um is put Eli Lilly in a bad situation
is the numbers down here right
and this is 33 and I think it got up to
almost uh 10 000 likes right yeah now
here's the trouble
and here's why Twitter is so effective
right and this is why we concentrate so
much on Twitter because Twitter really
is like the Gateway of information right
so when information drops on the
internet a lot of times it drops on
Twitter first and it it gets distributed
throughout other social media networks
um a lot of journalists drop their
stories on Twitter a lot of companies
drop announcements on Twitter's and the
reason why is because it's instantaneous
it's a very easy way to make an
announcement at Facebook kind of the
same way but it's it's just it doesn't
have the same effect as Twitter does now
the reason why this is so [ __ ]
dangerous not the Eli Lilly thing
because I don't believe this is
dangerous other than to Eli Lily's brand
and they should shoot I think they
should shoot sue the [ __ ] out of Elon
for this I mean the real the real fix
here if they I mean it also it's a very
interesting tactic too right uh because
you're claiming that this brand said
this thing and they're like we didn't
say this thing but it looks like you
guys said this thing now the way that if
I mean it's a bit of a power move
whoever did this because you force the
price and the stock to go down this is
the effect that was done at whenever
this is 1 17 p.m Eastern and this is
real this is the real Eli lilies yeah
this is the actual publicly traded
company and so if I really were Eli
Lilly I'd be like oh yeah [ __ ] man this
this person this fake account put us in
a corner now what they did was they said
oh we're so sorry this is a fake account
actually just follow us here you can
find out more information now a lot of
people started dragging Eli Lilly in the
[ __ ] comments and they're like if
you're really sorry you would do this or
you wouldn't try to take advantage of
people and charge them 300 plus dollars
it's twelve dollars in Canada why is it
300 in the U.S it's the same [ __ ]
drug so people were dragging them and
I'm like yeah [ __ ] good they should
be dragged I mean because what you're
saying is they didn't really they didn't
have sympathy for Eli Lilly that they
were parodied it was that hey you [ __ ]
you're sorry because someone [ __ ] with
your profitability right that's why
you're sorry you're not sorry to us
you're sorry that to yourself because it
shows in the market value right and they
said on their they said in a tweet they
said we apologize to those who have been
served a misleading message from a fake
Lily account our official Twitter
account is at lilypad
and so people were like oh well you know
and they and again like I said they got
dragged because they're like if you
really are sorry then you wouldn't be
[ __ ] taking advantage in in making
this drug that should be
very in a cost effect you know cost
effective for people or yeah uh you
should give them that you should you
should give them something that is
closer to what you're willing to charge
in Canada and I don't know what the
regulation is and obviously Joe Biden
and the Democrats are the only ones who
actually want to help Americans by
putting a cap on insulin uh versus the
Republicans are like yeah gauge
like that's literally what Republicans
want they want private capitalistic
companies to gouge Americans well that
way they get profits and they give them
money to you know for their campaigns
but the the the moral of the story is is
that this guy the dishonorable mention
is a [ __ ] bonehead yep he's a [ __ ]
bonehead and he keeps doing bone into
things keep it up Elon keep it up
because I'm questioning whether it's
actually an operation because you call
it the blue the blue check Ambush I'm
wondering if it's actual part of it the
part of it that's actually destroying
Elon is designed to destroy even Gabe
Sanchez we are at the point that we
reveal the bonehead of the week
for this Edition
who is our bonehead of the week for this
Edition well
tiny hands down it was Trump Donald
Trump Donald Trump trump wins the
bonehead of the week tiny hands down up
tiny hands down the guy it wasn't even
close they started they're like and he
just took off everyone was like yep
so when they voted like it came he came
out of the gate and he did not stop
right yeah they were voting on Twitter
and YouTube he got more votes he got
more votes on the bone-in Bowl than he
received for his candidates in the
primaries and that's are in the in
midterms that is why he's on the
bonehead of the week is because he lost
big there was no Red Wave not only that
but the reactions that he's had over the
last couple days
on true social to this guy dude I don't
know but like yesterday he openly
admitted or whether it's true or not
it's a big a No-No to what he's
admitting to what he admitted to was
telling the just forcing the FBI and U.S
attorneys to go down and guarantee that
Rick Scott and Ron DeSantis won their
election in 2018.
that might want to put up a couple
alarms
Crime Alert what you know for the Law
and Order and party they sure do like to
uh tweet out our truth out or whatever
the [ __ ] it is that they do on fraud
social true post their crimes but you
said here in a tweet so we gonna talk
about Trump sending the FBI and U.S
attorneys to steal the election for
Rhonda Santos and Rick Scott what the
[ __ ] because here is the here's the
actual this is one of like eight I think
that he sent but this is the one where
he's talking about right sending them
right because this was a big long uh
this is a big long tirade there's a big
long rant on true social and and Fox
News actually they played it maybe we
should find that video I think Jesse
Waters played it he played everything
but this this post here where he's
talking about how he directed the FBI
and the U.S attorneys to commit election
interference here's what it says and
Donald Trump the Cheeto death cue in
honor type this out on history so this
is real
I also this is what he says I also fixed
his campaign that's the words he used
I'm just reading what he typed out
which had completely Fallen apart
I was all in Veron and he mean Ron
DeSantis here
and he beat Gillum now this is in 2018
the governor's race where Rhonda Santos
beat Andrew Gillum now you underlined
the part that is the most important here
he said he goes on to say the Cheeto
desk q and honor goes on to say but
after the race when votes were being
stolen by the corrupt election process
in Broward County and Ron meaning
DeSantis was going down by 10 000 votes
a day
going or excuse me along with now
Senator Rick Scott I sent in the FBI and
the U.S attorneys
and the ballot theft immediately ended
just prior to them running out of the
votes necessary to win now Gabe I know
I'm no legal expert I'm not an attorney
I really don't even know
if this is
um real or not like if he's just
bullshitting
but this what he's saying on this post
rather it's real or not what he's typing
out is describing election interference
which is a crime yeah this is a I mean
in the end here's what he says at the
end I stopped his election from being
stolen literally he's saying that Gillum
was going to win Broward County and
Donald Trump I
stopped
Gillum I stole the election so that it
couldn't be stolen from Rhonda Sanderson
right that is what just so everyone
understands what he's saying he is
openly whether this is true or not he is
openly admitting because it is
questionable rather it's true right yeah
yeah but either way if you put this out
there you 100 are gonna have people
going uh we might want to look into that
whether again it's true or not or this
can be backed up and validated
but the fact that somebody would openly
admit and say yeah I I put government
resources down to Florida to make sure
that these two guys won
seems a little bit sus and also very
much a little a little a little bit less
in a very much illegal now I actually
believe that Donald Trump is doing what
he always does here he actually is
taking morsels of what is true right
little crumbs of Truth and he's building
this [ __ ] narrative around it right
so he's lying his ass off here now there
may be some truth in that he went to
people and said hey can we get the FBI
and the United States Attorney to go
make sure like and somebody might have
said yeah sure we'll do that we'll do
that right or they said you cannot do
that that is [ __ ] illegal like that
is election interference though everyone
involved will go to [ __ ] prison right
right so like
but I believe so there's some morsels of
facts in there and the the main morsel
effect is that this guy has no problem
interfering in elections like he did in
Georgia he has no problem in interfering
in elections like he tried with Rudy
Giuliani in Arizona with Rusty Bowers he
has no problem doing that he is openly
admitting maybe not to crimes that were
committed because who knows if he's
telling the truth if you really can't
tell at this point but he is openly
meaning that he is willing to use any
means necessary to interfere in a in a
free and fair election even all the way
back to 2018 and that is the most
important part this happened in 2018
this is not after 2020 or during 2020.
and this is prior to that he was willing
to steal elections right and the full
context is Trump is attacking DeSantis
is going after DeSantis because he sees
DeSantis as a threat to him running for
president right he wants to make an
announcement next Tuesday on November
15th and he wants to say I'm running for
[ __ ] president again everybody
I've been teasing the whole time now I'm
gonna run now he goes after Ron DeSantis
I guess he's trying to spread a bunch of
rumors there's a rolling stone article
that covered uh Donald Trump and even
then even then I was talking to Tony
last night because he didn't know about
this and I was like even Rolling Stone
yeah they were like uh we can't put any
of this stuff that you're claiming in
Prince you know we don't know if it's
true and we don't want to really touch
that [ __ ] with the 10-foot Pole right so
and it's got it's got to be because of
slander liable and everything else
because
we can't confirm any of the [ __ ] that
Donald Trump's saying and probably
because half of it is just [ __ ] lies
speaking of Lies look at these two hey
Jesse Waters Jesse Waters was on bone of
the week too and then kellyanne Conway
I'm surprised she hasn't made it on Bono
the week more often but here they
they're talking about again the messages
that the feud between DeSantis and Trump
they conveniently leave out the post
that we just showed you though where
he's talking about election crime but
let's listen to these boneheads so
here's a statement from former president
Donald Trump and this is a scorcher
right at Ron DeSantis oh my God a
classic Fox is all in for governor Ron
de sanctimonious an average Republican
governor with great public relations who
didn't have to close up his state but
did unlike other Republican Governors
whose overall numbers for a republican
were just average middle of the pack
including covid and who has the
advantage of sunshine where people from
badly run States up north would go no
matter who the governor was just like I
did when I endorsed him it was as though
to use a bad term a nuclear weapon went
off and then I got run by the star of
the Democrat Party Andrew Gillum who was
later revealed to be a crackhead by
having two massive rallies with tens of
thousands of people at each one I also
fixed his campaign which had completely
Fallen apart and now Ron de
sanctimonious is playing games the fake
news asks him if he's going to run if
president Trump runs and he says I'm
only focused on the governor's race I'm
not looking into the future well in
terms of loyalty in class that's really
not the right answer
did you catch all of that game because I
know that was just a bunch of [ __ ]
not only that this honestly makes me
feel that this is Donald Trump going
dear diary today Ron DeSantis was really
mean to me
and now I'm going to call him Ron to
sanctimonious and oh what people really
want to know is how much of a loser he
is that's what Trump is doing right
Trump is literally writing in his diary
because nobody is on [ __ ] true social
that really matters okay remember do you
remember the scene from is it mean girls
is that what that where where they have
like you're a Burnley [ __ ] that one
yeah they cut the [ __ ] picture out
it's almost like bonehead where they cut
the picture at your ear oh yeah oh yeah
she's a yeah it's all those rumors that
is exactly what he's doing that is
exactly what he's doing some 100 parody
i i i i as I was hearing that I was like
oh I gotta I gotta contact John Walsh
and tell him to do this yes he should
and so he should make a video about this
so let's listen to kellyanne's response
here though too the absolute word salad
that Jesse Waters just had to read live
on air
your reaction kellyanne Conway
I guess truth social doesn't have the
280 character limit
um
all right so here
that's her official response Gabe
Sanchez's wow he talks way too much like
literally that's her response as he
talks way too much I actually I actually
believe that this that this meltdown
that we're witnessing between Ronda
Santos and Donald Trump and the that the
fighting that Donald Trump wants once
here
is that Ron DeSantis collected a lot of
political capital in the midterm he
collected a lot of it and Donald Trump
wasted a [ __ ] ton of political capital
on on really dumb [ __ ] like
Kershaw Walker Dr Oz Carrie Lake even JD
Vance mastriano
um Blake Blake Masters uh fincham I mean
they he lost so [ __ ] big on the night
of the midterms and Ron DeSantis was
really the biggest red wave that there
was but it wasn't surprising in Florida
he's been able to gerrymander he's been
able to do things as Governor make sure
he's going to win to make sure that
stayed red and Florida is red I mean I
think we all have to come to terms with
it's red it's not going to flip blue
until there's a lot of things that
happen in that well yeah here's the
thing I do believe
that many of these states are blue I
believe that many of these people
support what Democrats are actually
putting forward however
again if you've got a team that uh has
control to make new rules
or you know I think there are four new
seats that were included resent one of
those four new seats including in
Florida right and if you're that you
know you're
if you're cutting new districts and
laying new lines and saying well
Democrats won this last time so in order
to remove that seat from them we need to
cut this up and rearrange it like you've
got Texas [ __ ] like uh
you've got Dan Crenshaw his thing looks
like a [ __ ] Arc it goes like an eye
patch Dan crenshaw's uh he looks like an
eye patch but here's here's the thing is
that I believe the reason why Donald
Trump is the bonehead of the week and
why he's freaking out so much is because
Ron DeSantis is really stealing his
mantle here without much without much
effort and that is what is terrifying
Donald Trump and he's doing what Donald
Trump always does is throw a [ __ ]
baby fit that is exactly what he's doing
that's why he's the bone of the week so
Gabe let's give the bone out of the week
Donald J Trump the Cheeto dust q and
honor his dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ER bonehead of the week you can always
you can always guarantee like almost
count on count on him Donald Trump who
is
broke also broken Donald Trump is broke
and broken he's lost his parties lost
his party he's lost his party and if you
want to participate in bonehead of the
week every single Friday come here to
the Tony Michaels podcast also we're
going to be playing a shortened version
on Midas Touch Network every single
Friday so don't forget to vote how do we
vote Gabe you go to the Tony Michaels
podcast YouTube channel click that
Community tab it'll be there every
Thursday to vote for bonehead leak also
you can go follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod you can also download
bonehead of the week the audio version
every single Sunday on Apple Spotify
Google don't forget to leave us a great
review while you're subscribing to your
favorite directory of the Tony Michaels
podcast Gabe this has been a great great
edition of bone of the week but I do
want to say one more thing before we go
because Ron DeSantis kind of slipped in
here on the opposite side of this
bonehead of the week so I want to give
everyone the opportunity to take a look
look at this design Ron DeSantis can go
[ __ ] himself go to
store.thetonymichaels.com that's
store.thetonymichaels.com to grab your
Rhonda santis can go [ __ ] himself merch
everyone
until next week this has been bone of
the week everyone on the podcast stick
around we got a few announcements
otherwise bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
bonehead of the week everyone loves
bonehead of the week and we've been
going a little long on Fridays because
of bone of the week but we don't really
mind that too much there's just so much
to talk about right now Gabe I asked
yesterday if we were going to be taking
a Thanksgiving break I think we're gonna
do that I think we've decided that we're
going to take Thursday and Friday off
for Thanksgiving and then we'll we'll be
announcing what our Christmas schedule
and our New Year's schedule will look
like we'll take something that's good
I'm gonna need a day to just kind of sit
the food off you know right right I just
gotta
relax not do anything right gluttony you
know right so so we will not we because
we all have Thursday and Friday off we
will not do a bonehead that week
unfortunately but we will have it back
the very next week we will have it back
the very next week and then we'll we'll
work on the Christmas schedule as well
to let you guys know that so we will be
out the Thursday and Friday of
Thanksgiving but we got a few more weeks
before that gets here and we got some
more accounting to do and Gabe I am
super super excited about the
possibility that the universe is going
to line up the story that I suggested
days ago where that control of the house
comes down to one seat and it will be
Lauren bobert losing that makes Nancy I
also see the speaker that I cannot wait
I hope this plays out just that way not
only will I be correct but oh my God can
you imagine for years to come I I will
be able to talk about how Lauren bobert
delivered us delivered us Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi it'll be fantastic so
everyone keep your eye on the counts
this week or this weekend stay with the
election there's going to be more votes
dropped there's probably going to be
some more races called everything is
going the way it needs to go for at
least whichever party to have control by
one maybe two votes in the house so this
is why it is so important that you lean
into democracy that you encourage people
to vote and that you vote yourself is
because every single vote counts every
single Race Matters and we will see that
play out next week here and hopefully
Arizona and Nevada work out to where um
this runoff is just you know just
something that we got to go through
right that we got to do so so everyone
have a great weekend stay safe same time
same place next week you know where to
go YouTube Twitter twitch noon Eastern
11 Central 9 Pacific and simulcasting
from Facebook until then Surfside
[ __ ] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn had asked Beacon